hey everyone diavolo here and today
we're back with the third the harai
Edition the absolute Pinnacle Edition
the peak by far the greatest Arc
throughout the amazing story that is
Hell's Paradise I just want to thank
everyone before we do move forward for
150 000 subs and all of the support over
the past few weeks here on the channel
it's been you know beyond insane to me
that I'm still somehow growing at this
point also once I finish this Last Arc
in this story which is the next one
after this obviously the entire story
will be up on patreon before the next
Arc is even here up on YouTube so if you
want to go and join pession and peep
that out then go and do that as it'll be
down in the description below but either
way when it comes to Hell's paradise's
harai Arc here it takes a turn for the
absolutely mental it initially focuses
on the alliance of the surviving
criminals and executioners invading her
eyes to retrieve the elixir of life and
escape the island however everything
changes after Lord tensin anticipates
their arrival plus like oh my God there
is so much more that happens so get
ready sit back grab a bag of popcorn and
a full fridge of supplies subscribe if
you haven't already because you need me
in your life push this video to 5K likes
and let's get into the harai arc from
hell's Paradise but before we go any
further I'm excited to say that this
video has been sponsored by swipe mouse
pads and like you guys actually need
these I didn't even realize that I did
it first because to be honest I don't
really want to post something to you
guys that I don't really care about but
this dope small company specializes in a
variety of anime and gaming bass pads
made to like Rez up your setup and oh my
lord they're nice the feel makes you
want to sleep on them they're nice and
thick if you spill your drink it doesn't
soak in like the water resistance is God
here the stitching is seamless they
don't seem to wear out quickly and
what's even cooler is that they've got
an anime based artist currently working
on a bunch more pads for all of us weebs
so if you guys do need to get a new
mouse pad and like you do then make sure
you check out Swipe mouse pads through
my link in the description or the top
comment down below and use code
volatility 15 off on your order overall
I really do recommend these bad boys
like I I used to run through a mouse pad
every few months with the amount of
editing that I do and like the moving
around and stuff but these are actually
theme and they just look that good Plus
what's even is it means swiper looking
to work together in the future with a
bunch of different things if stuff goes
well here so honestly like I truly do
mean it go check them out through my
link or like the top comment down below
and use code Volo to get 15 off on your
order because these mouse pads are
actually super high quality and I'd love
to work with them again in the future
and help grow their brand in general and
stuff but anyway enough of that enough
of me rambling on about like these mouse
pads and everything back to the video
for now
so after May does your thing Lucci
interprets for the group and begins
explaining the plan they're about to
undergo from what they can learn harai
is designed to be a massive Fortress
modeled of China's epank Palace and
these sea monsters prevent anything from
leaving the island however May reveals
that harai contains numerous ships and
an underground Floodgate that allows
departure along a safe current so the
mission is to avoid confrontation
Acquire The Elixir and steal a ship to
make it back home on Gabby Murray tells
them that according to May the 10 elixir
is located in a laboratory but the
palace's interior is constantly changing
we're time drawing closer to the moment
they invade enemy territory she unpauls
gamimaru and use a riha over to have
them instruct the group and the Art of
Espionage using Dao looking like an
absolute Bay with these specs on
yuzuriha teaches the group on how
they're to master their presence by
suppressing their Dao afterwards gaming
Haru also nerded out teaches his lesson
and using doubt against their opponents
after the training was over everyone is
divided into two teams the Escape Route
team made up of Big G Shion
and The Elixir retrieval team made up of
the other three so while the three
powerhouses are off doing their thing
sourcing The Elixir the Escape team
needs to find the boats and open the
floodgates realizing that may has wanted
to leave the island for a while now
again teacher's side suggests that they
let her depart alone and not wait for
the election team however Gabby marrow
asks May if there's anything she desired
to do before leaving the island
surprisingly May tells him that she
actually wished to meet with Rhian and
chofukua gang to ask them why they
changed from how they were before then
escaping remembering his wives words to
him about valuing every day and living a
decent life Gabi Morrow promises the
fulfill May's wish no matter what at
least the Miller time inside of arai
Delphi greets chobe at the end of the
Doshi ritual ceremony but is stopped by
ju far he cruelly tells the other teams
and that there is no need to communicate
with livestock and just breathing the
same ear makes him feel ill and
goodbye's presence juffar lashes out at
chobe who easily manages to block the
strike realizing just how much strong
he's become so tells the immortal that
he should have finished him off in the
last fight because now he can see
through all of his moves stopping them
from further escalating Reign orders too
far to behave himself and has chobe
follow him to his laboratory so that he
can study his Dao as the two walk and
talk chobe notices that he is starting
to get used to this new power but after
looking at Rhian census that his doubt
is on a completely different level
initially he was planning on escaping as
quickly as possible and running back to
Toma however after seeing the difference
in strength it decides to stick around
in case he can find some sort of
weakness once entering the laboratory we
see a massive watanowa flower which is
called ibanko these flowers don't allow
them to store extra tan but unlike these
smaller flowers it can process a far
greater quality of tan all in one go the
reason tan can't be reserved is because
over time Dao is away at that of the
human's life force eventually and just
like the human the plant will soon
wither before it can produce the perfect
quality tan this is why Rhian desires
chobe's rear Dow to complete his
research again with Yuki like referring
to something from our world here this
Banco or pangu and Chinese is an entity
that appears in prominent's creation
mirth and this creation myth it explains
that in a world of nothingness Banco was
the giant who emerged from his egg
separated Yen and yang with his ex
elevated the sky above the Earth and
upon his death turned himself into the
Sun Moon landscape wither and animals
pretty much it's the god of Earth in
this creation myth and possibly even
something similar and hell's Paradise
meanwhile The Elixir retrieval team
infiltrates rye and once safely landing
on the roofs signals to the others that
the area is clear to enter scary notices
that the plan is moving quickly and
wonders if it's truly time for the
mission to come to an end pulling up his
mask gabimaru states that they always
knew they were on a timer so yes
everyone will leave this island tonight
flashing back to the preparation Fuji
breaks down mei's explanation and gives
out a basic layout of the castle he
reveals that each tencent has a
sanctuary of their own and The Elixir
and the Escape ship are most likely in
the center area popping in May tells us
who was in each area of the castle in
her eyes The Elixir is most likely with
Rhian and the laboratory joofa and delfa
were between the old silly and subtly
botchujutsu sanctum the Thai sohu
sanctum as the domain of zhujin shuitsu
sanctum is the meditation domain ruled
by gufa and finally the shooting sanctum
run by Mudan but you know they man ain't
around anymore so there's probably no
one there for the time being at least
she also states that since the Banco
flowered droops at night Brienne will
not be in the temple conducting research
instead he'll most likely move to the
main residence with Joe fuku reside
making it possible to also avoid running
into him after securing The Elixir Gabby
Maru then explains that he and usuriha
will end atop the inner gate and will
survey the layout of the castle using
their Dao sincere in the present to
hearing notices a dreadfully Sinister
amount of Doubt coming from the palace
and starts to fall tour can be unusual
though console her stating that it
doesn't bother them as they're already
used to it using what they learned in
preparation for this Mission both Gabby
and usuryha take out all of the guards
while constantly keeping their Dow
suppressed not to alert anyone after
taking out all of the Doshi The Elixir
retrieval team successfully make it
through the first part of their
predetermined plan and into the castle
most instantly after getting inside they
make it into the supposed room with the
Elixir Gabby opens the door and sends
his layout of the room but suddenly sees
Dao forming an entity in the middle
surprise that someone knew he was there
the Dow silhouette is revealed to be ran
who had the same idea of suppressing his
energy if you ain't subscribed yet by
the way just just Dove it Stephen fourth
May asks your younger brother how he
knew of their arrival Ren commends them
for their attempt but reveals that chobe
has already informed them that the
humans would be coming to invade the
palace and agreed to keep track of their
arrival by simply Nadal on one condition
this is just due to the fact that after
who 13 his brother in their last battle
chobe was able to track his exact
location and because you know Toma is
with the group he probably knows where
the group is just like when he went up
against zujin Gabby Maro finds himself
in trouble due to ran possessing the
water attribute which hinders his fire
attribute the plan if they bumped into
an enemy with a stronger attribute was
to run as if they try fighting with such
a heavy debuff they've got no chance
hopping into a JoJo whisk pose ran
becomes delighted to see May once again
and begs her to return back to the SI
explaining that they no longer need to
follow the outer way of Dao since they
have completed their research in
creating the Elixir utterly shocked
Kevin asks for more info on what he just
said obviously because of the fact that
the tents and discovered chobe they feel
that with his cooperation they'll easily
be able to create a potent enough Elixir
all they need to do now is produce more
tan that has a considerable quantity of
exceptional material that's why for this
exact reason Rhian has started the right
of just consumption as the end is indeed
coming near despite his plea may have
fuses and says that she only wishes to
say goodbye to everyone to her now it's
obvious that she's different to them but
dying is sad instead she came to say
goodbye before leaving the island with
everyone else disappointed Rand state
that the right of just consumption will
have to continue and she can become
another offering artistic Gary asks what
he meant ran explains that it was a
ritual to capture and offer the humans
to the Grand Master over with the boat
Squad getting tips to saifuchi and Tomah
gets separated from Shion and nurugai
due to a massive cloud of mess that
obscures their Vision pushing forward
either way the three then bump into the
Delphi and do far while shiona narugai
are approached by Zoo Jin for a second
time knowing that they plan to avoid
Lord tense and has failed the group
decided to move on to this second plan
which is just straight up hands giving
everything they've got because it's not
like they're ever going to outrun these
fames not phased a boy announces to ran
that they won't give up without a fight
and instead they're gonna beat him down
and say goodbye to this island seen as
how the ritual has already begun ramp
appears to let loose knowing that all
they need now is sacrifices so I just
want you to all think back to the uh pod
analogy I used in one of the earlier
videos I'm pretty sure it was the very
first video and how it was literally
shown to us on the panels themselves now
think about like how what they're doing
with this Elixir is simply another form
of this old school Japanese curse
they're sticking all of these venomous
beasts into the island which is
literally shaped like a pot and the
hopes that they can procure a vial of
immortality juice I don't know it's just
something that clicked to my head right
now but I love how early on it's
foreshadowed that this exact thing would
happen with Toby figuring out that the
island is kind of like a bowl knowing
that even though he's going up against
someone with an unfair Advantage gaming
Mario tellsagiri and may to go search
for The Elixir while he and user riha
hold off the creature however Mei warns
him that they are not in rhian's Temple
shocking Gabby Maru since in the kit
coming at him from behind though he
quickly Dodges and jumps back before
flying forth at the immortal trying to
land a kick himself but ran comfortably
weaves out of the way hopping into an
unrealistically messed up pose ran
confirms his sister comments as he'd
reconstructed the palace before they
arrived apparently the Dao of inorganic
material was even easier to manipulate
than that of living creatures
constructing buildings and renovating
are all tasks that actually fought Ran
So it's even easier for him to control
that than others with that he creates
some spikes from the floor that trap May
leaving her with nowhere to run as he
slowly closes in on her needing to
protect May Gabby Mario decides to fight
but is unable to harm him due to not
possessing the right attribute
yusufrihost is an opening to attack and
throws a Dao impute kunai however the
kunai bounces off his body Judah ran
cloaking himself in a dowel like armor
getting caught off guard Reign slaps
them with a fat double kick that pushes
both Gabby and use a rehab bag observing
his Dow Gabby Mario can visibly see the
thick layer of armor protecting him from
any attacks the crazy thing about rand's
armor is that unlike traditional armor
that has holes under the armpits and
other vital spots where you like have to
move obviously bran has no gaps at all
to exploit it's almost as if his Dow and
muscles are in Perfect Harmony flesh
perfect did needing to force an opening
Gabby re-enters the battle and fights
ran vertically while they both stand on
a bunch of massive pillars rain jumps at
Gabby taking away a massive chunk of his
pillar however our man uses this to his
Advantage as he picks up the rocks and
activates nympho Stone storm sending
them rocketing back at the immortal not
phased due to the like Elemental diff
Rangers Returns the ability by kicking
him back at Gabby causing him to drop to
the ground Gabby then tells you to rehab
that it was time to begin the next
strategy confused after hearing this
bran examines his Dao and notices that
nothing has even changed so we can't see
how things would also change in the
battle random readies himself to fight
Gabby Mario who's now closing in however
everything suddenly vanishes from his
side before reappearing and Landing a
fat blow that sends the immortal
tumbling across the sanctuary so back
before the mission began Gabi Maru
explained that Dao was like a current of
water flowing around one's body it's
even tangible allowing the user to
change the speed size and strength the
attribute of God determines which
direction your energy flows you normally
have ways of combating opposite
attributes sadly though the doubt of the
current Lord tensions are so massive
that the normal rules do not apply
because of this gamero theorizes a
three-step process to use the enemy's
doubt against them firstly you're weaken
your own energy around a specific part
of your body to take in their Dow then
you've either can't so that the boasts
of Doubt spinning around your body
doesn't damage you but floats around
till you can reverse its polarity and
send it straight back at the opponent in
the prison gabymar smashes ran into the
ground by redirecting detention's Dao he
sinks his breathing with ram and falls
into place between tranquility and
serenity finding the middle ground and
allowing him to ward off any incoming
blows realizing that even getting grazed
by one of the Immortals attacks would be
brutal he considers studying the second
step to his plan but decides to hold off
for now solely healing himself bran
becomes impressed by Gabby Morrow's
skill with Dao he explains that the
thick lots of must tend to activate a
person's head and Powers when they
arrive yet he's just something else
Gabby and his eyes possesses sheer
Talent however Gabby Mario disagrees
with his coming stating that everything
that has happened was because of
everyone's efforts and the sacrifices
they've made along the way for the sole
purpose of defeating the Lord tensions
while Rand is less shocked with Gabby's
pure determination scary quickly frees
May from the restraint and lets the
others know they've got ahead for The
Elixir screaming at them to behave
themselves though Grant swings around
and attempts to stop them but has
stopped himself by Gary Morrow who yells
at the others to get it done still
trying to get past ran quickly figures
that Gabby's using his own doubt against
him and decides to suppress it yet as
soon as he does yuzuria comes in and
slices the plant man in two diving forth
once more she goes to finish the job but
is worn by Gabby to stop ran standing
there and impressed with his skills of
his enemies decides that in light of the
ritual he is not allowed to toy with
them his body then suddenly begins
turning into a bunch of flowers and
vines before exploding into his
forearmed kishikai state
elsewhere ran sets in the ritual Circle
and reviews the names of the human
Invaders given by chobay with zhujin
encountering shiona nirugai Rihanna
believes that he holds the advantage
since xion's wood dell have no effect
against zhujin's water Dao and aruga
isn't able to use his yet still he does
since a great deal of Rage coming from
them and knows that anger can greatly
increase someone's ability also at a
similar time gentitusai and fuchi face
dalfa and joofar Brienne believes that
his team will defeat them with ease as
neither of their opponents ever find
their Dao though he does take note of
Gabby Mo as he can sense that they need
to be extremely careful with him after
he finally finishes his review Ryan
presents the completed literature of
life to Joe fuku and announces that once
they defeat the human Invaders they will
be ready to depart to the mainland to
continue with the ultimate plan
meanwhile the assignment from the second
Landing party began exhausted after
traveling so far in such a short amount
of time after making it to the tan pits
all of them are disgusted and
disheartened once they find what remains
of Tim's Genji furious at the fact that
more of his close friends have died
before he was able to save them sugar
states that they have to make for harai
now once there everyone The Hermit and
the conflicts will be eviscerated having
also stolen one of these special floats
the Doshi used to control the monsoon
shugen blows it and commands them to
carry him and his crew to harai at once
back over with Gabby and uh remember in
his past discussion on how if the enemy
manages to redirect its Tower during the
fight it'll be impossible to win Gabby
Morrow comes up with the idea of
boasting yusu Ria's down viewed weapons
with his own to defeat Lord tension back
in the fight Gabby sees Ryan going into
attack and prepares to use the same plan
of redirecting his Dow however he end
user riha are completely dumbfounded
when a single punch from The Immortal
kishikai State blows apart the
surroundings while also knocking them
back following up ran absolutely pummels
the life out of yusu rihar and Gabby
sending out boys shooting outside of the
building and causing user to drop to her
knees severely injured elsewhere
sargerian may run throughout the palace
searching for the laboratory story May
notices the loud noises coming from the
Darwin Temple and becomes worried for
the Allies seguria assures me that
gabimara will be all right since he has
a backup plan but even still the idea of
him following through with that plan
worries her taking things up a level the
kishikai monster needs gavi causing
massive damage before following up and
smashing him into the ground
disappointed in how easily he's being
beaten Gabby takes note of how unlike
the previous Keyshia Kai's they've seen
rand's mind is still in control allowing
him to perform his techniques to an even
higher degree despite her past warnings
that when push comes to shove she'll dip
out of the fight use the riha leads
loose her rope ability to grab her
teammates in an attempt to try and
survive however ran catches up to them
and as she realizes that if she doesn't
Block it's the end for her Gabby Maro
manages to block the attack just in time
having had enough with this pathetic
cockroach of a human ran throws away any
idea of using Gabby Mario for tan and
instead smashes down breaking his guard
and seemingly ending our man's journey
home who top it off Brandon throws Gabby
into a pillar leaving him there to live
out his final moments lying there and
remembering all of the times Gabby had
said that his life takes priority and
that he wouldn't die until he makes it
home he again reiterates their thought
as man is not about to end at all no no
no no no no pricking his finger with one
of them are sneaky old flowers the young
man chooses to sacrifice whatever it
takes in order to be back with the one
that he loves regaining his footing
heavy Mark stands back up somehow fully
healed while revealing his black eye and
the vine-like patterns that stretch out
over the left side of his face so the
reason that Gabby can actually achieve
the state and not just Bloom into a
bunch of flowers like everyone else
who's been stung is for a very specific
reason pretty much if only a little bit
of tan makes it into the body it has the
possibility to balance out making
someone the same as tencen Gabi Mara who
had overheard this explanation got
everyone to accompany him to mudan's
pile of Bloom Flowers he then retrieved
one of the flower stingers and plan to
receive the same power as chobe by
overcoming the abification but at that
time May objected to doing so just do
how dangerous the risks are however
Gabby Mario reveals that he was already
aware of how Jobe managed to accomplish
this fate and is willing to take these
risks what separates chobe from everyone
else is that he has something to fight
for besides himself so when he's down on
his luck he finally strength to defy
death no matter what because he's got to
get back to his brother
back with the girls now cigarette
becomes shocked after only just learning
about part two of Gabby Mario's plan but
knows that he is willing to do anything
and he hopes of returning back to his
wife over in the battle Gabby Mario
Dodges out of the way of a few
thundering punches and Kirks focusing
himself Gabby knows that he needs to
take out Rand before the flowers take
over his body even still he notices that
Ran's attacks are starting to become
slower as he consumes more doubt
throughout the battle use a riha who's
still recovering from the previous
battle tells Gambit that he ain't normal
no matter what happens even if he does
die he doesn't stop pushing forward or
for the hopes of seeing someone that
might not even exist turning and looking
at her Gabby explains that yeah he he
might be crazy but there's only some
places idiots can truly rage someone who
keeps a cool kid and thinks logically
just won't survive there's times we have
just got to let loose he compliments
youzare as someone who pushes people
away on the odd chance that they might
make her an idiot hearing this she
becomes encouraged by Gabby to step
forth despite her wounds and fight with
her friend and they die of death
knowing that his fire Dao has no effect
on rand's water yamimaru tells you his
riha that they need to rely on an earth
Affinity to defeat him needing to make
an opening for her Gabby starts off by
activating his aesthetic form and using
nympho demonic fire bug to throw a burst
of fire at run the immortal easily
extinguishes the Flames but Gabby slides
in next to him and activates nympho
Burning Bridge sending a viable
rocketing towards rand's face slashing
his foot back ran comfortably dissipates
the Flames from around him yet as he
does so yuzuriha makes her move and
latches onto him with a mucus strings
thinking that's good enough to finish
him off give him a heads in and Dodges
an attack Rand makes towards tandem he
then uses nympho ascetic blaze in an
attempt to Scorch the creature but as he
looks down at his work sees a hand
reached through and toss him towards
youzury her slightly impressed Rand says
that even with their shame of theirs
it's only a futile struggle that's
prolonging the inevitable and yet it's
beautiful to behold here and Gabby talks
from smack Brandon prepares himself for
the final belt and tells him to show him
everything they have okay so like I I
hate to do this but I'm not going to hit
you with a 30 seconds of just like one
page techniques over and over and over
again I just it's fire what's going on
right here right now boys okay well but
reigniting the battle the two Shinobi
then unleash their various Ninjutsu
techniques in combination with each
other Gran somehow manages to block
every single ability and pushes them off
but suddenly notices that his body has
begun to crack while the immortal
randomly confused with what's just
happened Gabby Mario reveals that his
earlier attack was meant to over
stimulate ran in order to make him lose
his sense of judgment and timing
throughout the fight they were able to
stall for enough time with ran like not
knowing what's going on to have the
kishikai state use up all of its dowel
suddenly Rance Keyshia Kai form explodes
revealing is weakened and reforming
States giving Gaby marrow and yusarea a
perfect opening to attack as the two
Russian history starts to feel pain
coming from a wound but tries to endure
it until they can defeat ran Rising back
up in front of them Gabi Mario sees that
rare him managed to cancel out his form
before completely running out of Dao
while changing genders ran swiping to
Gabby making it obvious to the ninja
that he's trying to recover his lost Dao
by cycling between yin and yang he
screams out to use a riha to use her
ability before he recovers and hearing
this bran reaches out clutching down on
Gabby's shoulder telling him that it's
impossible he knows that the wound she
received earlier is extremely deep and
she should continue with her plan she
will die stopping a new tracks yuzuriha
agrees with Ran's statement and throws
her kunai away suddenly spinning around
though the queen catches a weapon and
Sparks up her down as it's time to
follow through with what she came here
to do slapping his hands together the
immortal goes on the defense by forming
a field of massive spikes in an attempt
to take yuzore down before she reaches
home putting out his hand Gabby helps
usurya avoid these spikes by flicking
her up into the air she then jumps down
off the ceiling and as she perceives the
remaining Dow inside rand's Tandon
annihilates it with the Earth Affinity
infused punai what the first battle here
coming to an end the immortal being then
starts to crumble away calling out for
his brother during his pitiful demise
what a battle as well like that was
gangster and that's only the beginning
of like this entire Arc oh you are not
you're not ready this whole Arc is just
there after that after like story after
Iran it's just oh my God it's so good
after watching ran fully turn into a
bunch of foliage now usually how warned
scarabimaru about the amplification
process eventually taking over his body
still in his eyes he knows that he had
no other options if he wanted to see his
wife again he then suggest that they
catch up to sargerian may but use a riha
needing to rest tells him to leave
without her before leaving yamimaru
tells you to read her that he'll be
waiting for her at the boat and also
once again thanks her for saving his
life when they first encountered each
other on the island but man this moment
always gets my my freaking tear ducts
rolling after being alone I use a riha
unbuttons her dress and removes the
mucus protecting the wound she received
earlier thinking to herself she finds it
sad that she never showed her heart to
anyone till the end she remained the
same always going at it alone whether
that be life or death knowing that her
life was at risk usually apologized to
her deceased sister sire she really
really tried to live for both of them
but this here this here is the end of
the road remembering what she said to
Santa when he passed she tells herself
those same words when it hurts go ahead
and think about whatever you want a pet
cat maybe a lover you left behind your
family pass on with that beautiful
Vision use a riha then faints with a
smile on your face after thinking about
sire as her final thoughts damn that
hurts I'm sorry I had to blow some stuff
there throughout like that battle and
everything as well yeah you you could
just had to calm down I don't know we
had to take a top off and everything but
yeah that obviously that just hurts my
soul and it was some brilliant riding on
Yuki's behalf but I I can't wait to you
know even get further into the story
right here everything ties up and
finishes so well nearby I walk every
Mario runs he remembers the plan that
they needed at least five people of
their group to help sail one of the
underground ships and goes to push forth
to the temple all however he stopped
still dropping to the ground as the
effects of the vines spread through his
body beginning to crawl now he remembers
user where he has words on how the more
he regenerates the quicker The Vines
will take hold thinking of this and
their look should have on her face if
she saw him now he fully collapses
before losing Consciousness moments
earlier though over in the uh you know
the cheeky our body Jutsu chamber if you
know what I mean the sanctum now gained
titusai and filchi majis and Tomer
encountered ju far Dao far and the
Bandit himself chobay seeing his brother
chobe puts out his hand and informs
Tomah that Lord tensin has agreed to
make them Immortal all he has to do now
is join them hearing this you know big
game teachers desire tells Tomah to
leave and rejoin his brother as he
doesn't think that them gaining one more
whim is gonna even out the odds I love
how I love how confident exercises after
saying goodbye Thomas walked up these
stairs to finally see his brother for
the first time in days instantly as the
boys see each other they break out in a
gleeful smile and slash at the two
Immortals standing next to them the
creatures try to retaliate but the boys
are able to overcome the monsters and
send them tumbling down the stairs
proudly standing there chobo tells his
bro that he was slow on the uptake but
can already sense that he's coming to
his own the reason that Tomah knew what
was going on is because they have the
hair done in a specific way with one you
know like side being tied I just thought
that was a cool like aspect done into
the story that you can kind of see when
they're lying between each other one of
those is done up but yeah continuing on
with a fat smile on his face he thanks
both against his side and booty for
keeping his brother safe and shows his
gratitude by having them take on Dao far
well they take on the other Immortal
themselves the entusai and fuchi then
watching shock as dalfa regenerates from
the previous attack and expresses her
disappointment in trobe's betrayal
getting the Babe's attention gen
teachers like points his blade towards
her and asks if he wanted him to take
away the pain over the other side of the
room the Bros then prepare to fight you
far who after recovering becomes enraged
at the fact that these people attacked
Del far so the the rematch begin from I
guess you know beforehand obviously just
like last time too far believed that
nothing is going to change no matter how
much they try dashing in the brothers
lay down a plethora of strikes that the
immortal manages to fend off dropping
down onto the floor Tomer jumps off
Toby's back and manages to land an
attack on ju far however he actually
juices this to catch Tomah off guard and
almost hits him with a volley of energy
balls having been pulled to the side in
time by his brother though the two of
them re-engage in a close combat Jewel
slashing at the immortal and slowly
beginning to push him back unable to
stop the force of the brothers from
pushing him back tomod darts and close
and manages to deal a significant strike
to the monster's face making it realize
that this battle is the complete
opposite to last time just like in the
battle with ran he then angrily decides
to ignore the ritual and take out the
two brothers meanwhile on the floor down
below kantechosa explodes after seeing
just how beautiful delphar truly is
after taking a compliment from thoughchi
she dashes that came to suicide and
attacks him with a strong punch before
following up and kicking him and the
kids sending him crashing towards a
pillar she's jokes that hearing some old
creep gork over her makes the skin on
her body crawl even though like she's
literally a thousand years old anyway
calling Fuji cute though she offers to
partake in a round of you know body
Jutsu with our boy hey my brother Fuji
hell with her Fuji cuts her off
literally and declines stating that he's
only interested in examining the
constructs of your biology picking
himself back up as well Big G becomes
excited with the idea of spending some
quality time with delphar wanting to get
down to business and continue with the
right of just consumption delfa then
bulks up the boys starting and slash at
her but the immortal easily takes
control over the battle comfortably
dodging all of their strikes jumping up
Delphi Let's Lose a wave of Dao that
pushes out from all around her flinging
out Guys across the entire room seeing
that they like can't defeat her by
normal means Fuji suggests that they
formulate a strategy to fight against
her ability to use Dao however can't
teach his size screams frustrated with
the notion of Dao as you know like
having heard the word a million times
isn't going to change anything in his
eyes plus he can't even remember half of
stuff it goes into actually using this
technique instead he just wants to have
fun in this battle he runs at the
immortal trying his best to take her out
while she's simultaneously mocks him for
not being able to use Dell bro the
amount of times I've sit down this video
someone needs to count it up because
it's got to be in the hundreds for sure
floating up Doubtfire lands a simple tap
on getting to exercise face but the
resulting blast was like it's in Forth a
flurry of Dow kicks and punches that
left him on the ground immobilized
dancing around him relentlessly mocking
him she tells against a side to give up
however Big G just refuses and comments
on how she must have had fun toying with
humans for the past 1 000 years after
hearing the statement delpha loses her
smile and expresses that all of this
time they've trained to achieve
immortality they lure humans over and
over and over for a thousand years yes
he's still somehow even now they haven't
been able to achieve the perfect
Immortal bodies they've all realized
that it's just that if she stops smiling
now she'll completely lose her mind or
maybe you know maybe she already has
she's in a taxi too with another blast
of Dow and disagrees with game teacher's
eye statement saying that the whole
process isn't fun at all having properly
experienced Dao for the first time Fuji
picks himself up and imagines the
breakthroughs he can make to Medical
Science with this knowledge also feeling
a little different the anti suicide
stands up excited to continue the battle
initially confused delphar is astonished
by the enemy's Ambitions that causes
them to continue fighting and senses
their Tower surging around them
sprinting at the immortal now Delphi
launches an invisible projectile towards
intensusai however he briefly centers
her attack and Dodgers shocking The
Immortal who receives a fatal Blow from
him
back before the oil all of the palace
Shion explained to nurugai Fuji and
gentichisai that they were unable to
sense Dao because they depend too much
on their eyes and battle to use Dao one
must attach themselves from reality and
or the body to embrace the sensation
laying there at the time and not
participating and learning hint isai
explains that he only believes in things
that he can cut or food she explains
that he can only accept things he can
touch in the present day after managing
to land his first attack on Dao far
gentle so figures they can use this
weird technique only for the tencent to
instantly retaliate synonyms shooting
into a pillar while saying that it was
probably just luck on their behalf Fuji
comes in from behind and manages to push
her away from gentitusai as he recovers
however she suddenly appears right in
front of him again and hits him with a
point-blank attack before grabbing him
by the neck and Blasting him with
another flurry of energy balls delphar
then drops Fuji while she comments on
How Sweet the links he was willing to go
to in order to help his friends were
battered and bruised Fuji says that
gentichisai wasn't his friend yet in
that moment he falls into a memory where
he told Big G they weren't friends but
they also weren't so different from each
other this didn't apply to like just him
as well all of the executioners at the
end of the day are just human and if
they make connections with someone it
leads to genuine feelings just like
anyone else and the short time that
they've spent together he was able to
observe that the samurai were no
different from the converse everyone is
made of skin and bone with an innate
desire to live from the bottom of his
little heart Fuji wished that gained his
side along with everyone else would
return home safely even if they never
spoke again after their day watching
their little man in front of him just
standing there against his senses that
is in massive danger and like the Mad
lad he is rips out his own freaking eye
back just before when he dodged that
blast he knew that he was reliant on
sensation and not sight now though man's
on a completely different level and can
perceive everything around him through
the use of Dao he quickly grabs fucci
and Dives out of the way before another
volley of energy balls could take them
out Stephen beckins are Fray gen teaches
us screams that every attack she hits
him with only increases his strength and
now he's eager to let loose flashing
back into the Past after a big man get
into Josiah was defeated by his former
Master turns out our big man's names
actually originally tetsuno suke and
while he was sitting there he wondered
how his master was able to defeat him
despite being an old knowing
that his pupil wants to learn more his
master explains that the young man has
become greedy with wanting to become
strong and tells him that he must let go
of his strength then let go of it some
more and he'll finally find everything
he wants now thinking on its statement
some more genticho reiterates that he
didn't have a clue what his master meant
back then yes and after a life of
mistakes he finally gets it the more you
gain the harder it is to take a good
look at yourself and the present Genji
Desai like the g e years manages to
dodge Delphos project darves and
continuously strikes away at her not
giving her a chance to regenerate
however his attacks are unable to stop
her from Reviving sadly again teacher's
side doesn't have to be right attribute
to properly take her down not wanting
the battle to like turn into one of
attrition Fuji knows that only his
middle down will be able to stop delphar
from regenerating and jumps in to grab
her so that it subsequently weakens The
Immortal allowing genticho to cut the
tandem with time beginning to slow as
Big G swings his blade towards the foe
he asks himself if he should just trust
this New Sensation remembering his
master's words again to stick good and
hard at what's left as in there he'll
find everything gantees his eye closes
his eyes and uses a dow infused stripe
to precisely cut the Immortals tandem
without harming Fuji who continued
holding her from behind
meanwhile over with uh the Bandit
himself chobe and his own battle
prepares to unleash his transformation
on juffa to increase his ability but is
stopped by Tomah who believes that they
can defeat him together hearing this The
Immortal faint tells them that they are
foolish for thinking they stand a chance
against him and his sister to which
choba explains that no matter where what
or who they are he always crushes his
opponents with his bro covering the
sides becoming enraged with a pathetic
livestock just won't end of this futile
battle Dickinson tells them that the
only thing they have in common is the
fact that they fight better in peers
reaching out his right hand another
suddenly reaches through the opening in
the curtain next to him down below it's
shown that the body of Delphi had begun
to bloom into a tree-like state with
fruit growing on each of its limb like
branches apologizing to his girl juffar
then begins fusing with the other tense
and while stating that together they
will obliterate them so as a child juffa
and dalfa were told that they were
special and that they were born as two
parts of a whole since then jufai
developed the urge to protect our far
and always came to May for answers and
one specific memory of his May tells him
that it was natural for him to care for
her since they were Partners the fact
that he is able to imagine the pain she
feels is perfect proof of that empathy
is both the root of uneasiness and
compassion yet because of what they are
it's inherently harder for them to
understand or internalize these thoughts
sadly though a change soon started
showing itself in riyan after he
introduces the five tencents of the hoco
he explained that they were allowed to
use them to replenish their Dao and
assign them their true training art in
an attempt to help them achieve
immortality both of them were in my eyes
disgustingly assigned with bochujutsu
like like come on man they were pretty
much family at this point and it's kind
of hard to make them do there during one
of like I guess the training sessions
Delphi expresses her Petty and using
hoco to replenish their Dao jufa agrees
with her which in turn causes Delphi to
feel happier that he understands exactly
how she feels after a few centuries had
passed shufar becomes frustrated that
the hoko on the verge of extension due
to the amplification and how riyan and
jofuku are not trying to fix the problem
gufa which is like one of the tents and
I'm pretty sure I hadn't mentioned
before suggested using the humans from
the mainland as another source watch
just like Mudan says if they don't do
exactly that then it's likely they'll
deplete their doubt over time and also
die after remembering everything Delphi
had gone through dufa becomes angry and
slams the table screaming that
everything they've been through has been
for nothing looking up he suddenly
starts to watch as the tension's faces
turn into smiling pits of Darkness
throwing what they've become he's such a
question if they've all gone mad that
the endless training drive them to
Insanity feeling broken inside he just
Ponders the thought that maybe it's him
and delphar that are The Crazy Ones
later he walks down to the floodgates
and sees that Mudan and dalfa are
preparing to send out abified hoco to
learn humans to the island shifa asks
his girl if she was okay with doing this
as after all she had in the past stated
that she didn't like treating the hoco
this way turning around with a beautiful
open smile on her face she confirms
answering with a yes while asking if
this was crazy of her nailing down next
to her juffar puts his arm around
delphar and tells her that she wasn't
crazy the humans are like the hoco lower
than the livestock and fit for their use
wondering if he's indeed crazy at this
point he pushes it to the side instead
thinking that it's the world around them
that's gone mad sadly back in the
present with the two finally becoming
won and transforming into the kishukai
state they look down with their own
crazy transformation telling the
pathetic humans that they're nothing
more than livestock damn and I always
always feel so bad for too far when I
first like read through there anyway he
just wanted his girl to be happy so he
followed her till the end of the Earth
and absolute respect for that man but
you probably shouldn't have done that
you ruined yourself have infused
together into the destructive embodiment
of love the Jeweler met an earpiece and
Screech causing troublemaking into so
and Fuji to immediately protect their
ears treby throws his sword to attack
but misses as the monster flies up
breaking through the ceiling of the
palace before ominously floating above
them in the night sky confused Fuji
begins to wonder how the monster was
able to fly with an unnatural proportion
however the way it captivates his
thoughts makes him feel as though it's
the embodiment of Love itself genticho
mocks chobi's earlier attack causing our
Bandit King to claim that he'll fight
Big G next after defeating this monster
Fuji tells ganti Josiah that they need
to administer first aid before he could
fight again however he refuses and says
that his only focus is on defeating the
Immortals looking at his friend though
Fuji watches as gintuchusai starts to
uncontrollably laugh quickly realizing
what's causing it he sees that one of
these spores the monster has sneakily
lit loose managed to sink into candy
exercise Nick having managed to like not
get hit himself he removes the Barb and
tells the others that it needs to get
undercover Toby knows that like he needs
to break the stalemate and prepares to
jump up and fight the monster he
transforms and sends forth a couple
vines that allow him to get a hold of
the immortal hang in there he then
morphs his hand into a mess of battle ax
and cuts dalfa's tandem with his Vines
making him realize that his mental
Affinity dominates one of the Immortals
would affinitys randomly splitting
itself in half the immortal then seems a
lightning fast barrage towards Cho Bay
which connects and manages to skewer him
then picking it up a notch the creature
boasts itself forwards before using that
momentum to send chobe flying across the
area and back through a building having
watched the scanted sir mocks chobe once
again while next to him Tomer panics
thinking that her brother is in danger
Fuji calms them down and says that there
is no way they could slash the monster
in one slice so in order to face it they
have to work together Big G and the
Bandit King exchanged some half ass and
salt about working with each other yet
as soon as the creature tries to attack
them they turn the anger towards it and
defleak the attack don't mean to like
pop in on myself here but I kind of just
realized Fuji literally replaced Santa
as a character with his entirety except
unlike Center he isn't afraid to inflict
injury on other people oh well he
reminds them all here that the enemy is
the kishikai amalgamation in front of
them and that they can focus on fighting
each other later if that's what they
want to do finally stepping forth with
everyone now planning to work together
chobe tomak and teacher society and
fuchi all vow to win with all of the
others standing behind him Toby
transforms and blocks the monster's Vine
attack growing to more branches The
Immortal shoots some Stingers towards
the ground but the Bandit throws himself
in front of them to save his bro from
being hurt while stuck dazed wondering
if he can even handle this foe chubby
reviews The Elemental attribute cycle
and knows that because of this secret
technique he has in store he's the only
one who can actually finish the
Immortals goofa Sprouts an extra Vine to
attack chobe but suddenly it's sliced in
half by Tomah he then grabs Fuji's hand
in order to strengthen his metal down
and dance forth with him to slice down
fast tandem get an in close Homer uses
Fuji's momentum and flings him and close
enough so that he's able to land a slice
on the Tandon since in an opportunity
genital side jumps in to deliver his
attack but accidentally slurps and falls
into the pool as the monster itself once
again flies up into the sky standing
there chubby sees Tomah arguing with
Gente Josiah and remembers how like
throughout their entire life so far he's
never seen the side of him throughout
their childhood he was always someone
who could only ever follow in someone's
footsteps but now he's noticed that his
brother has slowly started to become his
own person realizing that you know like
they probably they probably should be
focused on the battle here Toby points
everyone's attention up to the newly
evolved monster still floating in the
sky knowing that they can't defeat the
monster without destroying both tandem
simultaneously Toby assigns himself with
ganti Desai in order to kill jifa with
the strategy he has planned while the
leftovers Tomah and uh Fuji deal with
Del far reverting back to his uh simple
mistake he asks his brother what he
should do now Toby though simply punches
him in the head demanding that he make
his own decisions now since his faith
and his brother's abilities can teachers
isn't exactly chill about like teaming
up with chobe and is initially reluctant
to listen to his orders but after the
Bandit complements her strength man gets
straight manipulated into fighting with
him Jimmy looks over towards the monster
and notes that they are similar for the
fact that both Duos are willing to
protect their own and his eyes though
Tomah has grown to the point where he no
longer needs protection and because of
that state that he will rip them both
apart so that they can pass on together
super super nice of you Cho Bay to let
them are die and go to the afterlife
together and all anyway skipping Back to
Before the battle began we see that rein
while setting up the ritual of right
consumption told Toby that his brother
bears and Ill Omen back in the present
time chobe Toma gangster and Fuji all
trials towards the kishikai monster
while constantly fainting off baraja
Vines turning to the small man Genesis
tells him to give him some cover as he
Dives forth in an attempt to cut it down
seeing him get hit directly though by
multiple Vines and causes Fuji to think
that the swordsman has almost reached
his limit the monster launches this
spores towards Fuji but having seen
their attack and time is protected by
Tomer who throws his own body in front
of Earth needing to step out of like the
days that he caught himself in Thomas
shakes him around and explains that his
doubt is vital in their plan of winning
jumping up into the sky chobe notices
that everyone is on their last legs but
this is it they won't have another a
chance to win claiming that he's ready
now the big man himself manages to sneak
under the monster through the water
before popping up and sending a massive
slash directly up through the immortal
cutting it in half and leaving the
others for the perfect opportunity to
take it down Fuji Tomah and chobe think
coming from both sides swinging their
attacks towards the Immortals joofa and
dalfa try to reconnect the kishikai form
but just before they are able to do so
our team successfully destroys the
Tandon of both Immortals screaming for
her partner delpha emerges from the pool
weakened but has quickly stopped and
held on the Arms by fucci who tells her
just to stop as these are refinal
moments juffar then also climbs out of
the water extremely weakened and tries
to attack chobay since his dad wouldn't
be able to hinder them chobe punches
himself in the gut and removes two
bottles of water down that he originally
planned to use against Gabi Maru he then
pours the liquid on ju far which almost
acts like an acid to stop him from
regenerating basking in Victory chobe
just tells the creature that he should
never have picked a fight with the other
brothers
randomly gained his Psy comes in and
finishes the job causing chobe to think
that the man was taking Petty on the
creature when in all reality man just
wandered up the KD and our big brute's
head though his thoughts are slightly
different while remembering delphi's
words from their last battle he kneels
down and places a page from delphi's
body next to ju far thanking her for the
fun they had throughout this fight as he
slowly dies and tears appear in his eyes
chufa apologizes to his girl for not
being able to protect her now appearing
as children in a different world which
obviously like represents the most sane
and happiest time probably in both of
their lives I'd imagine before all of
the weirdities started happening either
way the two of them then Embrace each
other in the afterlife with Delphi
saying that she was glad he was her
partner back in reality and with the
battle having been won Fuji wonders how
the others are currently fearing then
once again going back to a bit of an
earlier time zagarian May encounter
goofah who says that he won't attack
them if they don't move from where they
are but also heirs that he will
absolutely crush them if they even take
one step forward after arriving May
pointed out that this was the ringtone
Temple yet Rhian wasn't here so she just
casually asked her fellow Immortal where
they could have gone gufa says that
Rhian had left not too long ago and he
was given the task to guard the ritual
Circle goofa explains that the items in
front of him are meant to tell the
fortune and current status of the humans
fighting against the other team sins
which is how he knew that her and may
were on the way here scary then reaches
for a sword causing gufa to Omit their
doubt towards sagiri and a similar
manner to someone overwhelming a person
with their Aura which causes siguri to
collapse from the pressure impressed
with the fact that she can still move
though who far tells her that if she
does continue to resist he will crush
her siguri explains that she does not
wish to fight and instead places her
sword on the ground while apologizing
for invading their Island along with
their behavior since then with that said
though she's Phantom pathetic how he
tries to stop her when all along they
were purposely luring in people to the
island this conflict is merely an
extension of what they sowed and said
deadly with how things are now it's only
going to result in more losses in an
attempt to prevent this though Security
offers a declaration of peace between
both sides they will leave and the
Immortals will allow it to happen
without delay hearing this goofard drops
the holy head over zagiri and allows you
to move once more however he warns them
that even if they return back to waguo
it would be pointless wanting to know
what they mean by this The Immortal
explains to the two through an illusion
created by GAO that rhian's true plan is
to depart her eye on a ship and release
the paradise butterflies on the mainland
turning every human into Watson who were
flowers then once all of the humans had
turned they would form together into one
giant Banco called The Divine Beast
Banco from that Rhian can finally
produce the much sought after perfected
tan hearing this shakes out girls to her
core as finally for the first time in
the series someone of normal sanity
found out the truth about Ryan's
maniacal plan by the way wagowo I
probably said that completely wrong is
the ancient Chinese name for Japan
pronounced wakuko and Japanese funnily
enough the name actually came about in
the 3rd century and it literally meant
dwarf country later on in the 7th
Century though and to amend their short
shaming the Japanese people changed the
kanji up to mean peace and Harmony
siguri asks goofa why why would they all
go to these links what could possibly be
motivating them he says that they isn't
him and the other tension feel nothing
for humans and that they are materials
for them to use in order to make an
Elixir hearing this change in her old
friend May object to the statement
saying that Joe fuku's original research
was for the good of mankind and using
lives as end yet and gufar's eyes
they've all changed ever since one
specific day and watched the autistic
specific method and manage to lure in
the first group of humans to the island
on that day they learned just how
beautiful and delicious humans truly are
it was more than they ever expected
humans outside of harai were weak frail
things yet they possessed far more
Exquisite material the reason for this
is because humans are beans full of
doubt and indecision they waver between
the extremes which itself is the essence
of Dao love and hate life and death due
to the tensions being born as higher
beings they simply cannot feather those
aspects of Dao so the goofah it's
frankly Unthinkable that they would look
for a more suitable form of immortality
a lecture at this point with the
election completed by Rhian who far also
says that to come to an understanding
would be meaningless and all they can do
now is try and steal more lives from
each other looking over his shoulder the
dude then points out that as they speak
shion's Talisman is beginning to burn up
symbolizing that in his battle he's
nearing the end of his road over in his
fight with zhujin Shield manages to cut
the Immortals body 215 times looking at
the thing in front of him he comes to a
quick conclusion that his plan is
working the creature is beginning to
slow its regeneration speed walking up
to it once more she aren't absolutely
exhausted continues to attack slicing
the thing in half again then after
getting right above the creature zhujin
quickly Springs back and manages to get
some distance between theme in an
attempt to regenerate nurugai goes to
attack herself but she unholds her back
while explaining that the monster itself
is also just as naked terrified and
unable to take them out so Jin just asks
what in the world Shion is as he
definitely isn't normal remembering here
at the moment where everything first
changed for xion he grits his teeth and
tells the fame that those who steal the
lives of others willingly could never
understand while those who have been
stolen from will never forget looking
like an actual 80 year old bag of bones
now so Jin defends themselves by
attacking the jewel with the remains of
all of the other bodies that have been
generated throughout the battle however
Shion sees through his opponent's Rose
and slices the Dow infused bodies to
birds hitting jumps forth using the
infamous Ito Ryu havershare but fails to
land a hit on a fleeing Immortal so Jin
initially thinks she or misjudged the
distance between them but the reality of
his attack was revealed when the Blind
King acting like he is perfect 2020
Vision fakes a trip and grabs the tip of
his sword from the ground and throws it
towards zujin's tandem getting up from
his injury Sujin sees that Shield
himself is just as exhausted from using
too much of his Dow and in that moment
takes the opportunity to attack the rogo
runs towards Shion to a system but as
per usual she is told to stay back as he
doesn't want to put her in danger sadly
xujin uses this moment to her advantage
and seemingly crushes Shay on what the
Dow bodies laughing out loud thinking
that she'd managed to take down one of
her opponents Sujin is probably
gobsmacked as they watch she on slice
his way out of the body coffin and utter
shock at xion's determination so Jin
asks why why would he shave away at his
own life force and go so far to Avengers
Fallen comrade standing there utterly
broken over everything that has happened
on this island Shion explains that he
hasn't had a single chance to feel grief
or mourn at times he even finds it
difficult to rage still no matter what
he states that until he managed to rid
the Earth of these pathetic creatures
the grief despair nothing will return to
him he wonders how many more hundreds of
cuts it'll take until he can finally put
his student and best friend to rest
literally just in fear for their life at
this point the creature makes a
last-ditch effort to heal itself by
slipping backwards into the water coming
back up it's shown that somehow in just
a matter of moments Sujin was able to
heal themselves by taking a leaf out of
gufa's book so unlike all of the others
or like the other tencent Hoopa take and
bought you Jutsu goofard doesn't he
finds it disgusting instead he maintains
a middle ground between both yin and
yang soojin then tries something new on
the side of the tencent and begins to
partially transform the body into the
kishkai form stand in there and looking
just super freaking clean now like like
the foot actually goes way too hard on
the immortal right here she taunts Shion
asking if it was still possible for him
to land all of those carts just like
with tenza zujin states that it is
accustomed to their tricks and it's
fairly evident as the three begin their
fight once more that shield and Uruguay
are only barely able to hold on against
the partial kishikai form tricks though
this statement said by zhujin hits
probably one of the saddest notes within
one of her favorite characters as it's
literally who she on is a trickster he
couldn't care what this pathetic
amalgamation of leaves thought his
mother was the one who gave him these
scars he was always born blind but
because he was also born as a traveling
performer it was a necessity to trip
people into giving them some measly
donations to live over time he came to
be known as the Divine boy who could see
through anyone's swordsman's shirt
without even saying moving forth
throughout his life she remembers how
one day it led him to the todozer which
is actually like a real-life Guild for
blind men to join and the King yo what's
the highest ranking member of their org
and lasted from The 14th Century all the
way through to 1871 and there was also a
female section called the gozaiza the
highest ranking member which was the
Grand kygo was set with the authority
equal to a daimyo once that said Keiko
and house Paradise heard of xion's
abilities it was through him that he
managed to end up as a student of the
Yamada Clan to not Sully his mother's
honor she only went along with the false
backstory that he was the illegitimate
child of a famous swordsman and kept his
real past life a secret from the Yamada
Clan even still this fact shames him to
his core after becoming a fully grown
adult and hearing 19 to speak his mind
to Shogun about how he should see him
for what he is now along with watching
him gradually gain acceptance despite
his past she only becomes inspired to be
like a student just like how he grew
into the man he was back in the present
she unblocks one of zujin's attacks and
states that no matter what if it's just
this one it will die by his hand he will
gladly give his life that cause quickly
leaning back he Dodges zujin's lightning
Dao attack and hears them gloating about
how he does not set a chance against
their power she un angrily silences
zhujin before they could finish their
sentence and declares that he will
defeat them that form is merely a cheap
trick that prioritizes performance over
dealing destructive blows he tells
naruga to stay back as he will end this
himself before rushing in and detaching
sujin's left hand then in the same
moment plunges his snapped Katana deep
into her Tandon remembering the
survivor's strategy making about how
they need to Target Lord tensions plant
like ovules to deal with finishing blow
xion disembodies xujin with his blade
then said it above presses his sword
down on the tenten's ovule to end the
battle while doing so Shion is assaulted
by the remains of Sujin sending a bunch
of the vines shooting into his body they
explained that they need to pull the
blade out otherwise the obvious will
continue to attack the one who holds the
blade down however she'll continues to
press down on her sword knowing that if
they both die then he will still be
victorious in the end nerugo worries
that if xiong continues with holding
down his sword then he will die however
Shion tells you to stay back he
expresses the pain he found as he left
tenza behind to fight for their lives
and plead to naruga to leave him behind
as he takes responsibility for his past
actions he finds it horrid that he made
the correct choice to flee in the past
and now all he can do is this his eyes
don't shed tears so he's unable to show
how much he truly cared Naruto tries to
intervene and talk to him but she
understood Minds that she flees causing
her to turn and run away as tears begin
to fall from her face she knows exactly
what his Sensei is going through now as
she's been in the exact same shoes she
could never forgive herself instead she
thought that she was the reason everyone
in her life died yet after meeting tenza
seeing his actions and hearing him say
that he was unable to accept her reason
for wanting to die it causes her to stop
and look at the blade in front of her
beginning to walk now she thinks he's a
vision of tenza bending down in front of
her before standing up and gifting the
real guy back who played new guy tries
to explain her situation but before she
can even verbalize what's going on tends
to hold out her Blade with one hand and
says that if that's the case then
there's only one thing to do encouraged
by her man the world got grabs the blade
and boosts it back towards the palace
inside of the building Shion is fully
covered with the vines and sadly
starting to feel his life being eaten
away this alone to him confirms that
just like him the immortal was also
slowly beginning to fade away however
nurigo suddenly flies through tackling
xion and frame him from the death grip
that he was in after tearing away the
remaining Vines urugu behatsu sensei in
an attempt to restore his Dow sitting
there absolutely exhausted now morogo
points out that the immortal is slowly
regenerating but at this speed it'll
most likely take a whole day to recover
she unbelieves that they should take it
out now since it's nice and easy but in
Roca objects and tells him that that's
exactly why they've got to leave if
anyone even tries to get close to the
creature when it's in that state then
the vines will immediately skewer anyone
so instead they should leave and get to
the others xion he just can't seem to
bring himself to this though he finds it
impossible to leave but that specific
creature still sucks an ear finally
nurugo tells him that that isn't it he's
wrong Tintin never died with pain or
regret she saw it with her own eyes he
was smiling because he knew that the
people he loved were able to escape and
was the smile of someone who was proud
in their final moments but also an air
of sadness she doesn't think that he
regretted a thing about his final
moments walking up to him Ruger hugs
Shion and asks that instead of holding
revenge in his heart he tell her all
about the man that he used to be after
she unlocks towards the blade embedded
in Sujin he notices the reflection of
tenza beside him and a rugai finally
feeling somewhat at PACE now she on
thanks to a real guy for raising him
with him and agrees to leave back over
at the ritual Circle two bottles
suddenly shatter while in another slowly
begins to crack this here obviously
indicates that instead of the criminals
or executioners they are members of the
Lord tencents have been defeated pretty
much simultaneously noticing that the
talismans remained intact after the
battles concluded scary believes that
Gabby Maru and the others are still
alive with the ritual pretty much over
goofar gets up and prepares to report to
ryun confused scary Christians go far
while they weren't willing to avenge
their comrades pretty much this is just
due to like the fact that these tents
and supposedly carry no emotion or bonds
with one another instead their passings
were merely a larger part of their
training in the way of Yin and Yang
goofa even reminds Mei that the same
went for her the tents in our beans they
only seek the way no bonds or emotion
what they've seen from her is only an ex
created by a Lost Child confused as to
why she would even reveal herself after
leaving who far inquires as to why she
came back although May still hardly able
to verbalize yourself just answers that
she finally understands what life means
turning back goofah just sadly responds
that he does indeed Envy her honestly
grufa along with I think it was delpha
were really the only other two tencent
to see kind of how messed up their ways
had become maybe too far A little bit
there obviously May understands as well
hence like why she left I just think the
reason the other toad didn't is because
they do truly have emotions and never
wanted to break away from what they've
come to know either way everyone is
suddenly taken off guard as the palace
then begins to violently shake with
grufas saying that the situation has
taken a turn for the worse outside it's
revealed that the maniacal Maniac the
order 66 Merchant Rank 2 Yamada Simon
shugen riding atop his Munch and smashes
through the wall they're made up her
eyes surroundings back over with the
larger Squad and after having given
gentitsu an eye patch to help protect
his left eye fuchi Toma and big chi have
a comedic discussion about its
positioning chobe hilariously interrupts
the conversation calling them utter
fools for weaning away time and quickly
brings their focus back to the main
issue at hand he reveals to them all
Ryan's plan of turning every human in
Japan into tan synchronizing them all
with the monster called Banco he also
remembers how Ryan told him that he was
confident that the other tencent
wouldn't die but also stated that if
they did happen to die then it would not
matter to him Toby listens to gain
teacher's wife's complaints about how he
finds the situation far too complicated
and also agrees with Fuji's suggestion
on his eye patch much to the
assignment's happiness Tomah getting a
little curious as to what his brothers
got an up to with attention and choirs
but is utterly shocked after Toby
reveals that he engaged and bought you
Jutsu and was constantly experimented on
knowing that they must stop reyan and
retrieve his ship from The Floodgate to
escape themselves though she asks chobe
if he is willing to Ally with him before
he could give them an answer though the
four suddenly feel the room begin to
tremble meanwhile naruga helped Shield
up so that the two can walk together
while he's still injured she uninsures
naruga that even if things don't go as
they planned and they end up in the
worst possible scenario then he will
ensure her that she still still able to
survive and return home Edo though would
not be their destination instead they
will roam the country together in the
current time period there are still a
fair few Mountain Clans that remain
hidden maybe living life that way will
suit them both he gets down on his knees
and promises that so long as life Burns
in his eyes he'll be her protector until
that day comes the two then you know get
into a good old comedic discussion about
another one of our shion's blind
metaphors there when they both suddenly
feel the palace begin to start shaking
after the Tremors settled down Shion is
unable to detect what caused dirt all
around them though appearing from the
darkness it would ninja masks
breakthrough from these Shadows with one
in front of the duo telling them that
they have been ordered by shugen to
eliminate all convicts in any of Simon
who have sided with them at the same
time ganti zusai and the other three
there along with the currently
unconscious Gaby Mara are surrounded by
various ninja instantly the ninja around
Gabby lash out in an attempt to take him
out however gabri Morrow wakes up and in
one perfect motion takes up all four
enemies after looking and realizing that
it was even one inches he's just Merc
is here and what is uh what does Gabby
mean by that I'd love to know your guys
initial thoughts down in the comment
section below so and they flash back
during the first night they camped out
on the island it's shown that sargary
was constantly told by Gabby marrow that
she was feeling sleepy even though she
denied it shiruka means though that he
sleeps after the battles he's Ford but
is quickly told that people like him and
Ewa are able to go for at least 10 days
without sleep with this in mind she
asked as to why Gabby Mario was even
worried about people coming after him
gabri Morrow tells sagiri that he has no
doubt that they'll track him down and
find him hearing him scary becomes
confused by this as to like why would
they go out of their way for just one
straight ninja so this is like as Gabby
Mario reveals here for one simple fact
the condemnation Gabby Mario the hollow
is a code name meant to carry and passed
down through iwaka Curry's strongest
Shinobi sangibimaro like 12 times in one
sentence here is going to make her brain
explode better either way well when the
chief found Gabby with his milk's
parents turns out that they do there
next to him was the previous Gaby Maru
he wasn't telling algebi to necessarily
behold weakness but instead the current
gabimaru of that time who I'm guessing
was the one who probably moved Gabby's
parents otherwise how did the dude like
gain that position and let's give his
parents were just like random ninja and
trying to leave the village and it's
just me who's read way too much into the
scene here but moving forward either way
back when Santa was alive and during the
time he was a riha and him ran off to
evade the Flames she actually explains
this possibility to the weeb king she
went over the horrific tale of Gaby
Murray the hollow and how the name alone
was the only thing she knew was real
she's almost certain she heard tales
about how even if gabiara was slain he
still somehow shows back up and wreaks
Havoc even more than before decades pass
but this name never ages or dies it's as
if it's a living breathing
representation of Terror seemingly
falling into a flashback of Gabby's own
memories it shows the Edward Gray's
Chief telling the potential young Gabby
candidates on Hell we'll pick from one
of them to become the next inheritor
during the training the Chiefs hit
Society high on the young gebby marrow
like the one that we know for his
impressive skills and lack of emotions
so Gabby uh used to be kind of different
I guess you could say this dumb kid once
threw a rock at his head and um well
yeah you can you you guys can see what
happened here Gabby didn't have a gabby
doesn't know what the middle ground is
after finding out what happened the
chief asked the previous Gary Morrow
only one who possibly committed this act
and it's assumed that Al Gabby kind of
you know kind of popped off here as the
early days brutalization continued
throughout the clan the chief takes note
on how each of the victims separated the
Young ebimaru from the week so that now
only those who are like-minded equals
remain later on one of these Shinobi
comes up to Gabby Mario after becoming
impressed that he carried out A
Dangerous Mission with admirers and
Pierce at envy him along with having
true Talent the chief decides that
kebimara will be the next Shinobi to
inherit the Alias the chief tells Gabby
Murray that he has chosen him as a mixed
successor and must complete a ceremony
where he has to take out the current
Gabby Murrow in a fight to the death I'm
assuming this is with absolute he's had
our boy once here as we don't even see
what happens the previous Gabby Mario
just got completely off screen by our
boy in a matter of moments overly
enjoyed with just like how broken Gabby
Amaro is that she screams into life he
will become history strongest Gabby
Mario the hollow back in the present now
sugar Odyssey ninja to execute any life
form they come across except the other
surviving Yamada then just as abruptly
leaves with Isuzu and kiromaru while
nearby chica decides to guard the rear
when intellectuality man's just trying
to do the least work possible looking up
to the ninja next to him Jacob says that
he knows this whole obey the shogunate
concept is just a front used to hide
their own agenda on the mission thinking
back the specific ninja remembers the
chief's orders to kill gabimaru in order
to become the next Gabby Maro the hollow
themselves standing up she tells jika
that they share the same goal since
they're the end of the day their
objective is to kill everyone else on
the island however the ninja tells
themselves that the only thing that was
more important than actually taking out
Gabby was to bring him back looking up
with a maniacal expression on his face
dementia just remembers that after all
she was the one who slaughtered everyone
in his way and took out those who were
envious of his success after confronting
her the ninja admits to this she
explains that they have been supporting
him all along from the shadows and
confess their failings to him that they
love him they're the behavior to die by
his hands or kill him
Yuki just came out the bag with like a
maxed out clingy ex-girlfriend right
here holy that's like the
personification of actual crazy crazy
also on another note those are masks and
Ninja Warrior resemble the ones used in
North theater not drama is the older
surviving form of Japanese theater it
combines music dance and acting to
communicate Buddhist themes the
tradition began throughout like the moro
Machi period with around 60 masks that
originally had like religious
connotations funnily enough and you all
probably saw this coming Gabby's crazy
girl we just met wisdom Master
represents a jealous female demon back
in the dips a variety inside of the
floodgates reinstances the Tremors
coming from outside and is also reported
to by goofar that the other remaining
tencent have been killed the right of
just conception has failed and extremely
skilled human reinforcements have
arrived with no other choice reinstages
a counter-attack by Smither Doshi out
for battle we'll keep in a minimum
number with him as protection as they
Rush towards the battlefield Rhian
reiterates that This Is War the losses
and outcome of this battle made are not
the before long everything should return
to how it once was above ground now we
see everyone including the Doshi right
in the states beginning to throw hands
seeing as how they can't manage to
defeat every single fodder opponent
against his fuchi Toma and chobe decide
to instead make a run for it over in
another battle she unprocures himself a
sword from one of the ninja and is told
by neru guy to follow her to safety
while sprinting away themselves anti
suicide lets them all know that he knows
a thing or two about experiencing War
these fights they're currently in go Way
Beyond just putting strength against
strength in war Lavina dine is complete
luck there's no fun about the battles
and no Pride at all to be won It's Only
Hell on Earth any people who survive are
only those that run those who have porn
to do their bidding and the complete mad
men with Gods on their side over with
one of these uh Mad Men as the Doshi
Army charged towards him shugen
remembers Eisen and is driven to cut
down the entire freaking Army and only a
few deadly swings after seeing sugan's
battle skills kirimara asked him if he
had some experience with war however
he's quickly told by him that this
battle was in war it's an execution to
purge this scum who dared to defy The
shogun's Honorable blade testers he then
commands as two underlings to cut off
the enemy's Escape Routes and slaughter
them all at the floodgates Reign
encounters the so-called wannabe Gabby
Mario and a surprise that he couldn't
detect their presence at all Gabby's uh
stalker here says that they have no
desire to fight with Rhian and is sure
that if they just waited here give me
Mario himself might come to the
floodgates getting curious himself and
while asking if this person happens to
be from the mainland Rhian also commands
the Doshi to take them out however the
Second Heavy Mario here just like Gabby
did with sagiri asks if they'd like to
see some Ninjutsu before suddenly using
nympho aesthetic Blaze to incinerate the
Doshi with the area around the beginning
to catch fire their ninja orders its
clansmen to burn all of these ships
except for one while they themselves
take on riyan back inside of the um good
old Renton sanctum sargerian May are
confronted by the Doshi and iwa ninja
siguri sees the ninja charging towards
her and instantly defends Yourself by
sensing the Dow to track the flow of
their movements while fighting off
everyone she notices that the Doshi
don't track May while the Shinobi do not
attack her because of her position in
the clan believing that it's most likely
due to the specific orders each side was
given she comes to the conclusion that
the key to winning lies in exploiting
this weirdity the two Doshi then come
charging into attack however hail it's
time they randomly pulled away from the
two by a random sticky string of course
it's no one other than this sneaky
kuluichi herself use a reha seeing that
uh seeing that a friend is still somehow
alive after her previous bout she runs
in and gives her a hug pretty much like
we all got heartbaited on thinking that
uh our girl passed away there when in
all reality she just actually had to
kind of take a nap but if you kind of
think about it in the perspective there
when you usually get injured and need to
go to sleep you usually think your body
shouldn't gonna die so it makes sense
that she probably thought it was the end
of the road for her but turning out that
after a nap she's back then noticing one
random small ninja yuzuriha finishes off
a small group of them and explains the
scary that before messing up with him
she checked out the surrounding area the
situation is probably the worst they
could be in right now as they are
seemingly cornered by all four battles
that are happening around them since the
Shinobi were high by the Shogun Sierra
thinks that they could persuade them to
fight like together with them however
usuryha tells her that it just wasn't
possible since they are out to kill all
of the criminals and reminds sagiri that
the task in coming here has not changed
scary knows this and points out that the
Elixir is most likely the floodgates as
well scenes are Gary for the first time
since arriving on the island Isuzu
becomes relieved but is shocked as he
was standing next to the criminal user
riha of keishu scary tries to explain to
her that like she and the other
executioners had no other choice but to
team up with the criminals given their
situation she tells her that many lies
were stolen by this woman's hand so
think of her victims do not dishonor
them as usual reha is truly a Villain at
the same time hiramaru confronts Shion
and irugo while confronts chobe
and Toma Isuzu explains in combination
with the others that each criminal
animal creature are the enemies and
anyone who's willing to help them even
the assignment are also seen as an enemy
now with that said Isuzu asks sagiri to
move away from usury her and come join
her side meanwhile kentinsusai and Fuji
who'd like temporarily separated
themselves from the other brothers run
off in an attempt to find an Escape
Route catching their attention though
and slowly appearing through the Shadows
behind them it turns out to be no one
other than shugen looking rizz out of
his freaking mind like like the first is
actually Darth Maul spec anyway standing
there in front of him getting his sign
notices just how menacing this dude is
realizing their food she is untied as
criminals hands shooken then angrily
demands and he'd give him a proper
reason as to why when you're in what's
up with this like uptight weirdo
gantitousai tries doing a similar thing
like he did with Gabby Morrow back in uh
one of the earlier arcs to feel out how
his opponent might fight however sugar
ceased through its intentions and
silences him telling him teaches aside
that he only watches to speak with Fuji
ganti's side just stands there
dumbfounded as to like who sugar is
since unlike the other opponents he has
faced he is unable to get an exact read
on what he's packing shugan who's still
not over the first question he asked
yells out to Fuji to explain the reason
why his criminals hands are untied like
we all know from everything that's
happened so far in the island Fuji tries
telling him that they had no other
choice but to Ally themselves with the
criminals due to their extreme
circumstances shooken here's this reason
but like as he's here now tells him that
he no longer has to be back against his
side and can be hit him instead he
pleads with fucci to not throw away all
of the memories they have together all
of the times they spoke about anatomy
and the paths that he has chosen in life
saddened with the reality of the
situation Fuji says that he also
cherishes the time to spend together
learning about life through his
experimentations but also says that
before coming to the island he didn't
understand the value of life no not
until the death of his close friend he
instead draws his sword and apologizes
for disappointing him but what they need
to do now is focus on escaping they can
worry about everything else later after
drawing out his sword sugar shocked he
said that Fuji used the Suba as getting
to exercise eye patch to him and most
other Samurai is like we've been over
before as well he played as a Warrior's
Soul the Yamada Soul fioris he screamed
it if he's misplaced his soul then he'll
be forced to but before he can even
finish his sentence man is cut off by
the Big G who himself became
dissatisfied at the fact that shugan
just assumed he could murk him with ease
instantly the two clashed swords and
while stuck in a blade tussle Tamaya
knows that he's fine and should be able
to throw him around with his size
Advantage one of the tussle like he
thought then teacher side manages to
knock Shogun off his fate however as he
thinks he can take advantage of the
scenario notices that the samurai had
legitimately transformed into someone
else having gained some distance Big G
instantly closes his hand and goes to
strike down on him but shoe can easily
block scan his eyes next attack and
takes the time to tell him about the
fond memories he had helping Yamada
Simon Genji with his calligraphy as he
starts to describe Genji shuken's
strength increases and causes gante's
Society to see him as an image of Genji
now she now with this massive strength
buff deflects can't use those attack and
challenges him with all of the fallen
and even like some of the like alive
Yamada beginning to appear as Spirits
behind sugar Stakes they don't will not
be him who delivers the final blow but
the blades of all Yamada are Simon as
the belt begins shuken uses Genji's Helm
splitter technique to completely off
balance gantechosai who was unable to
counter before the samurai disarms him
having lost his sword and with no other
option left gender side throws a punch
but shooken once again avoids the attack
by imitating Keisha's ability with his
big guy beginning to fall over shooken
explains the kind of man that Keisha was
though he really asserted himself into
conversation he was a genius when it
came to foreseen and Warden off attacks
she unsuddenly uses a combination of
both keisho's Harvest shawa and Genji's
Helm diverse in an attempt to mortally
wound the criminal dropping to his knees
against I say said he wished he got to
play some more but now he's slowly
starting to fade not taking him entirely
seriously she on screams that Mercy
isn't meant for the likes of criminals
no
this this is an execution having swung
the blade down atop Big G shugan is left
mortified to find that no one other than
Fuji had somehow managed to block the
strike Fuji tries explaining that crime
and evil are the same Genesis is
undoubtedly a criminal but by no means
is he evil he tells him that he's just
over this whole thing he doesn't want
anyone else to pass on even if it means
turning his back on the laws of this era
having heard these words sugan sees that
Fuji hasn't changed since the first time
they met and yeah I'll I'd love to go
over what they did here just so you know
best of buds you know back in these old
days doing like little little
experimentations on people and stuff but
you know YouTube these days anyways as
we bang it back to reality shukin
suddenly slash his foot Chic before he
even had the chance to react with tears
beginning to fall from his face shooting
just remarks that he was just a blind
man till the end someone who only ever
put those in front of himself elsewhere
inside of the ringtone Temple Isuzu
explains to zakira that she has faith in
Shogun because he upholds order he
protects those who abide by the law and
punishes those who go against them the
level of crime does not matter in his
eyes it's the standard itself that needs
to be upheld at the same time chobe and
Thomas surrender she only lays down his
weapon and Gabby marrow is approached by
two ninja with faces resembling iwaka
Crow's Chief and his wife back with the
Fallen Fuji though again teacher so I
think that it's mental Shogun would ever
go that far for the sake of order
absolutely raging out at this point
shugan screams that no this isn't crazy
what he witnessed was pure determination
from which there is no return and for
that reason he condemns Tamaya a villain
before seemingly finishing it all so
elsewhere at the floodgates and
manipulating the Flames themselves Freon
controls his second Gabby maro's fine
and Jitsu and uses it against the
surrounding ninja taking out a bunch of
them before they even got a chance to
react dodging another blast to herself
the female Gabby throws a kunai rien
which connects directly with the
Immortals phase but after it recovers
immediately Caesar not only can the
being you sorcery but also regenerate
thinking back to what Gabby Maro said to
her earlier in life about her no matter
what the situation and Umi is toy
physical being if it has a conscious
mind then a strategy can be formed with
that in mind the Second Heavy Mario
places out of hands onto the shoulder of
some ninjas and commands them to use the
last of their lives to set these ships
Ablaze not only the ships to burn up
otherwise all the butterflies and the
whole plan goes up on Flames Ren tries
to manipulate Dao in an attempt to crush
the ninjas boarding the shirt unable to
stop everyone and seeing just how tense
ran had become the Second Heavy Mario
calls out that she'd found her love to
her it's obvious that she'd been holding
back as to not damage the surroundings
but in reality it's only when these
ships get damaged that cause rain true
pain pondering if it's a possible love
the ninja states that at times it can be
a Troublesome thing and it others a
strength but in this fight here it is
indeed the immortal's weakness all of
the surrounding ninja what seemingly
keep appearing from cracks cynical Thor
or shuriken towards the creature ran
then easily blocks off the basic attack
but is shocked to see that the elixir of
life has been taken from her by the
second Gabi Maro who without a second
thought then tosses it to another ninja
and commands them to get it outside
asrin tries to stop them facing gebimaru
activates ninpo pyro bridge to launch a
torrent of fire that completely engulfs
the immortal Rian doesn't drop their
concentration over which Ninja has the
Elixir though and destroys them with a
shot of Dao however at some comes with
your attention that one of the items
they were carrying was the squad
Leader's mask and the other with the
Elixir had managed to escape the female
Gabby knows that she stands no chance of
winning when it comes to strength but
this is war when someone is an
unfavorable condition they must exploit
the enemy's point of view to create
chaos that way any outcome is possible
as in war it is only strong who Prevail
it's the wicked and twisted after
bringing the Elixir outside the Shinobi
pulls out a massive seashell and signals
the team that it has been acquired Isuzu
hears the signal indicating to her that
their mission is now complete use the
riha who's like on the ground in front
of her unable to deal massive damage due
to like still needing to heal attempts
to fight Isuzu without a full power
seeing these slimy strength coming
towards her Isuzu easily counters by
kicking Rubble up from the ground below
scary quickly darts in and gets his Rita
out of the way while asking her fellow
executioner to calm down as useful reha
is not a villain I suddenly enraged by
the fact that siguri just won't listen
Isuzu responds by telling her that even
though they captured the Elixir she will
not stand to see any of the criminals
alive before they leave going into a
small flashback it shows that even
though Isuzu didn't exactly have a bond
with everyone inside of the dojo she
felt a connection with siguri the first
time they met since they were females in
the Yamada Clan so now to see a team
belt with an enemy on the island it
makes her enraged meanwhile Gabby Mario
watches as the toshinobi kinkakubo and
genkakubo use transformation Jutsu to
reform their faces into the iwaka Crow's
Chief and his wife speaking as the chief
he tells gabimuru that he's been
expelled from the clan No Grave shall
bear his name as to leave the village
means that you no longer exist in
reality speaking of reality same goes
for his wife apparently she is only an
illusion created as a shame to help
imprison his heart inside of the clan
however it sadly backfired in this case
funnily enough gabimaru compliments the
two Ninja on their depth use of like
Transformations YouTube and hearing them
do so makes the big guy Shadow with joy
over the fact that Gabby Mario would say
so hearing these two talks wrong about
the next Gabby murrow's instructions our
boy easily figures that the next game
which the two confirmed along with this
they also updated the previous Commander
that kumukeri along with the others had
perished on The Voyage to the island
they also insisted on telling Gabby Maro
that shijia was obviously the person who
mocked all of the other candidates and
then in their eyes they still view him
as the true Gaby Maru finally I can lick
my brain wrist now and just refer to the
female Gabby as shiji now holy like the
idea that her name wasn't mentioned up
to this point just blew my mind when I
first went through and reread this Arc
anyway after they also hit a massive
trumpet go off the guys that could be no
that it informs him that they've
actually acquired the elixir of Life
they're moving on to like the issue at
hand kingakubo humbly asks gabri Morrow
to end his life as this way the chief
will remove the kill order on him and if
he wants he can make it Painless by
licking the Ninja's toxic Survivor Kevin
Morrow obviously found this method of
theirs to be completely utterly gross
but it's big by Kinka Kubo to reconsider
since in their hearts they're all allies
pointing out to them that the hen
entered his throne hands range Gabby
Praises them for following the basic
ninja principle
despite this Gabby Mario flexes his
bloodlust and causes them to stumble
backwards somewhat annoyed thinker Kubo
asked if he was still willing to defy
the chief and hearing that Gaby Morrow
planned to escape this place kokukubo
tells him that even if he does make it
back to Japan yui does not exist
obviously our boys heard this botas take
how many times now man just can't fathom
the idea that she isn't alive especially
since he knows the people from Eva
specialize in psychological warfare so
in his eyes he has to see her to believe
it although they were unable to raise
him with him and much to like the
annoyance of Gabby Maru kenger Kubo says
that he and the others are all delighted
that he refused since this gives him a
chance to fight to the death with the
current Gabby Mario of iwaka gray
everyone inside of like the clan
obviously looks up to him especially the
young Lanes the idea that they all get
to fight him in Mortal Kombat is a dream
funnily enough some of the higher
rankings even drop down to get the
opportunity to become fodder on this
Mission just so they had the chance to
throw hands with Gabby bowing their
heads in honor of what's about to come
the plethora of in and rushed towards
gavimaro however using Dow sensation and
looking like he perceives absolutely
everything in reality right now it's
like some Gojo spec giving Mario quickly
deals with the ninja dodging in and out
of all of their attacks and using their
own weapons against them while they
fought a loser's dealt with Gabby tells
them all that iruka Curry's tactics such
as psychological warfare and numbers
will not work on him kekakubo notices
that like our boy has become a lot
stronger but is corrected by the ninja
saying that no he finally learned to
become weak he then states that he
doesn't care who he has to fight whether
it's through Lord tension or every iwaka
Curry even these new Yamada they stand
in his way and try to hinder him from
Escape he will obliterate everyone and
everything
dude I laughed so hard at this part when
I like first read through it and
everything you've seen it you'll see in
a moment what I mean but we'll just skip
around here quickly so you get the idea
well as Kevin Morrow quickly begins
taking down all of the Gideon who will
like overly satisfied they all introduce
themselves before instantly being murked
by our man who all the while lets them
know what they did wrong with their
techniques training them and their final
moments like a true king ending the beat
down though Gabby Maro takes out the
final attacking ninja with a fat cat
completely cracking the floor they're
standing on going Byakugan mode all of a
sudden Gabby activates his Dow and takes
the opportunity to sense the palace's
layout to reveal any skirmishes taking
place between enemies and allies quickly
dodging a random fighter ninja that
tried attacking from behind he also
sends us that shija is located at the
floodgates in a boat siguri is safe for
the time being but he is shocked to see
that food she had fallen keeping the
mission as his main Priority First Gabby
ignores the testing the others to rush
towards the ringtone Temple to meet up
with zagiri steal the elixir of life on
the ninja Squad and Lead through the
floodgates to reunite with his wife
meanwhile zhujin's plant like remains
suddenly reawaken then slowly moving it
leaves the taisoku temple and takes the
underground water system to eventually
reach the Divine Beast Banco
remembering like Ryan's past explanation
about how the banker required more high
quality Dow to stay alive and that
consuming it would be dangerous Zoo Jin
and their half-baked State throws the
warnings aside and makes its way into
the amalgamation of vines to become one
with the Divine Beast erupting from the
top of the palace wood and other
remnants of it go flying everywhere as
zujin emerges completely fused with a
Divine Banco and draws everyone's
attention at a similar time it's
revealed that chobe allowed himself and
Toma to be captured by the enemy as he
believed that it's better to bite his
time rather than fight while outnumbered
however Toby bazali starts to feel a
pain coming from his arm which as jika
starts to ask him what's up flowers
become uncontrollably sprouting from his
body while this like occurrence is
happening it captured Doshi walks out in
front of jika and starts to transform
Blake back into a human with a dude's
sentience returning he just wonders as
to like where he is and the whereabouts
of his allies and like how he even
arrived him to begin with at the same
time Gabby Morrow's flower Dao also
starts to react and his body begins
sprouting flowers across her looking
into the distance and seeing the massive
flower monster he assumes that is that's
most likely got something to do with
that thing at the floodgates Ryan's body
also reacts and while sensing what
caused this change finds it zhujin head
merge of the Divine Banco the zujin
fused banko then releases a plethora of
roots which begin to track to any large
source of Doubt transforming him into
trees in the process over in the
ringtone Temple scary notices that May's
body is starting to react to the Banco
causing usuzu to rush outside and find
out what exactly has happened only
making it to the doorway though she then
becomes horrified as she looks outside
witnessing multiple sunflower like human
trees mixed with taller munchin and
social stuck in these as in pose walking
through them towards the center of her
eye meanwhile sugar notices that Gente
isai and thought she had managed to
disappear and instead only finds a
flower bed in front of him while this
has been going on ran thinks back to an
old conversation he had with ran in it
he was saddened about how the Divine
Banco wilted but refused any thought of
either 210 as it was just strong to
control even for them the tencent it
would throw off the delicate balance of
Dao that gives them form in reality and
sadly because of what zujin has done
everything will have to start anew
endlessly they shall return to the
outset just like before their hopes are
dashed a feeling one only gets when
traveling between jigo garaku itself
having heard reinstate this once again
bran asks why he would go so far what is
he truly trying to achieve here
shugan who's still looking at the
flowers in front of him realizes that
both Gucci and contagious I hadn't left
but were covered by them and wonders
what could have possibly caused Earth
his theme found by iwaku horoshinobi who
have come to confirm that shiji was
taken out while fighting Rin but managed
to stall her momentarily and now the
Tintin is about to leave on a ship after
getting the elixir of life from them
shook an orders a ninja to uncover gantu
Desai and vote his bodies from the
flowers and confirm their status once
shugen had left though and made his way
to the floodgates and iwugukuro Shinobi
reforms the face and reveals themselves
to be shija in Disguise stating that
they had substituted themselves with
another iwakukuro Shinobi allowing them
to escape they then for good measure
throw tokunai at the flower bed to make
sure that kantusai and Fuji don't
survive shija then jumps up onto a roof
and once she sees just how messed up the
area has become states that it's almost
as if they are on the other side seeing
the massive Banco monster in front of
her she realizes that mere mortals are
no match for such a thing laughing now
she leaps from the building and some
Hector looking JoJo's pose ready for her
otherworldly death match against Gabby
Maru shortly after Fuji still somehow
alive wakes up and comes to the
conclusion that Sugar must have held
back as he definitely could have ended
him there looking over to his man he
sees that gante Josiah is in a terrible
condition and decides that instead of
treating himself he needs to help him
with his hands trembling Fuji tries
focusing on treating his wounds until he
sees an apparition of himself telling
him that he should give up since this
new outlook of his own life will not do
a much good in this era this is an era
in which mean happily surrendered their
lives of a superior command set one in
which a son takes pride in serving as a
kaishaku shugen is a perfect
representation of this and that's why he
acts this way he knows that the Yamada
claim is already treated like a band of
ronin and this could cause them to be
disowned by the Shogun Fuji's operation
plays with him to Noah's place as if he
emerges from this it'll ruin everything
with Fuji slowly beginning to fade he
tells himself that the clan does matter
a lot to him and he doesn't want it to
be disbanded still he believes that what
he's learned on this island matters and
now he's beginning to lose his mind over
these competing emotions he knows that
he truly does want to support ganti's
Josiah and even though she tried to end
his life he doesn't blame him in the end
he just wonders if this is what it means
to be human opening his eyes to the
sound of someone mumbling getting to his
sight and certainly Rises to his knees
and panics seeing Fuji lying down dead
in front of him realizing that he had
given everything just to heal him
screaming at him he asks if the Yamada
or Simon Fuji really just went and saved
his life unable to open his eyes or even
respond Fuji who's still somehow lied
just becomes delighted to hear that game
teacher's eye called him by his name for
the first time and his last thoughts
Fuji warned shugen that the survivors
are not to be underestimated since he
has observed the world to continue
fighting no matter what everything and
everyone on the island is a walking
Paradox Fuji then happily waves goodbye
as he accepts his fate and tells us all
that he hopes everyone's dreams become
realized enemies and allies alike and my
throat like has a media sized Rock in it
right now they're harder than senses
death in my box I don't know if it's
because I love these two guys the most
and the interactions with both yuzuriha
and Genji desire but seeing him happy
for everyone here in the end figuring
out how we truly felt towards people and
how we came to see that everyone was
similar is just a great way to end a
character that like I initially thought
was a simple replacement for the weeb
king plus to those saying like in my
last video that this was just hands like
yeah a lot of it is but it's also just
jam-packed with proper character
development on each side and enough
World building so that we don't feel
like we're missing out on some like
massive piece of info might sound crazy
but for like how concise and quickly
like the story is moving it's still
smashing everything I wanted to know and
more plus the art that Yuki has just
been showing recently is God here in
this Arc also I just you know I probably
should mention this but big Gary marrow
just ripped off the flowers that were
around his body
several minutes before everything went
down goofar into the main Temple Annex
to protect the Basin as ordered by Rhian
while looking through the flame thingy
he's holding goofard becomes confused if
this was indeed reying's true plan all
along in the present shugen is told by
the iwakukuro Shinobi to not engage the
giant monsters since the touch will
cause him to be engulfed by flowers not
bothered by this sugar makes quick work
of the monsters using Santa's fighting
style and cries upon thinking about his
passing pushing forth he notices that
the Banco isn't paying attention to him
and makes a run for it to enter the main
Temple before the vines could block his
path meanwhile sagiri usariha and Isuzu
defend themselves against the monsters
next to them and Cena said let the Dow
around is being disrupted May slowly
begins to start blooming herself seeing
her they all realize that they must do
something quickly before it's too late
for May usurya swings up to get a good
look at zhujin and after saying that
it's blocking the entrance to the
floodgates with vines and monsters notes
that it seems as if they're back at
square one she then sees that zagaria is
trying to convince ice Isuzu into
cooperating with the convex but to no
avail wanting help who mate she drops in
and tries her hand in persuading her
however ganti design also arrives
carrying Fuji's body while boldly
stating that they do not need to join
forces with her as after all it was
shugen who took down Fuji after the
group berries fochi in flowers Gente
suicide directs his anger towards Isuzu
and once again says that they do not
need her help agreeing with him though
asusu says that they do not need to
cooperate it's shugen is still here
members of this Mission weren't chosen
because of their innate ability rather
the three of them were ideal disposable
pawns set up for the amusement of the
Shogun if it were a priority of them to
end this Mission they would have
selected Shogun to begin with as his
power is incomparable use of riha who
like knows that they need help becomes
annoyed with isuzu's stubbornness after
she continuously refuses and calls her a
gorilla only for Isuzu to get hit with a
fat dose of that childhood pdsd and
reply that guerrillism body the very
concept of Bushido getting down on her
knees Isuzu then intends to commit
sapuku to take response ability for the
death of your comrades in hopes that her
death will appease a Shogun as everyone
continues to bicker amongst each other
chica arrives with Tomah chobe kiyomaru
shigon nurugai and the iwakukuro Shinobi
Jacob tells azuzu that if he doesn't
return home then the responsibility will
line Shogun to commit Kuma side however
he does also say that he just came up
with a great plan that will be able to
defeat zujin and might have a way for
the criminals to earn their freedom but
needs assistance from Gabby Morrowind
order to do so remember how I brought up
that uh like Divine Banker was literally
the god of creation and creation myth
earlier in the video well now we've seen
everything what do you think about that
being like the reality of it in the
series it just kind of needed I guess
one of these tense and to control it to
become like a living being on this
planet like a like a Titan in some kind
of aspect anyway moving forth chobe was
suffering from zhujin's effects on his
body explains to everyone that according
to May the Divine Banco had spread all
over the palace and that the fragments
in the air are tan particles from the
flowers which will cause anyone to
undergo albufecation if an inhaled may
also warns them that they will have
until morning to destroy it or
everyone's doubt will be disrupted and
cause them to turn into flowers knowing
that they have to stop it to destroy the
Tandon tribulates them all know that he
sent us the Banco has five tandons of
each of the five elements scattered
around the grounds of her eye after
remembering how he like won their fight
with joofa and dalfa again to so
predicts that they'll probably have to
destroy all of the banco's tandem
simultaneously looking around at the
state of everyone here xion becomes
concerned with the condition since the
battle with the tencents has left him in
a bad shape to continue fighting as a
few larger monsters roll up behind their
group everyone easily takes care of them
destroying them in an instant after
hearing sugary and Uruguay make
excellent points about needing enough
doubt to destroy the Banco and stop the
monsters from pestering them jika while
lazily big chilling on the floor tells
them all that they need Gabby Maro to
handle this problem which you know like
I went over just before except this is
much more expanded on then out of
freaking nowhere segeric Ducks after
Cincinnati fire tauren coming from
behind her which incinerates all of the
monsters and reveals that the one and
only Getty Maru has arrived however due
to him being inflicted by the banco's
effects he collapses to the ground after
finally reuniting with everyone with
Gaby morrow in a bad State C said
he has to change his plans and turns his
attention to the eweka kuroshinobi
beside him obviously gabimara was super
glad to see that sagiri is okay since he
reminds her that he needs her in order
to return and receive the pardon despite
everyone feeling exhausted chobe says
that they have to fight back no matter
what happens he then walks up to
gabimaru and compliments him on the
first battle before stating that given
what he's saying it's fairly evident
that he's also got something to lose to
watch out better than bruised Gabby
confidently says that he does and that
nothing else mattered to him chobe
becomes satisfied after hearing this
from him and share on who's like close
by then looks at naruga and sees that he
also has something to lose chica then
walks up to Isuzu who wonders of
gabimaru his Charmed segari after seeing
her wanting to help him she knows that
she's swore not to defy her brother's
Legacy by working with these criminals
so instead
when she can with everyone on board now
Jacob prepares the disgustly plan but
wishes for xion to explain it instead
much to his annoyance while Gabby Morrow
is seemingly distracted the ewoker
kuroshinobi reading themselves while
remembering a specific Shinobi principle
when going for the kill keep your prison
suppressed no movement that it'll come
as naturally as breathing then as if
nothing is out of the ordinary they all
take the opportunity to attack him with
throwing kunai any moments before they
strike from these Shadows Shion
explained to the I like unaware group
that it's hand and can only be destroyed
by a user with the correct doubt
attribute and Dao restoration will
increase the attack potency Maiden
confirms like the Dao attributes of
everyone who's like in the group and
because we know everyone I'll just go
over the ones that we don't know jika is
Earth here kumaro with metal and Isuzu
who has their water Dao wondering if the
scruffy dude is anyone like you can
count on use a rehire questions to Gary
about his skill to which she also
becomes unsure due to the bad rumors
about him these bad rumors by the way
are that like he pawned his blade away
so that the one he has now is trash and
often gets on the bows with the boys not
complaining his assignments while
they're distracted the itward Shinobi
throw their kunai gabiomaru in an
attempt to finish their mission randomly
though chica notices their attack and
turns asking if they really want to go
through with this so you see even sagiri
has been confused for a while as to why
jikarus rank 3 and even asked Shion back
in the day Shion states that taking his
personality into account he's the lowest
of lows it was confirmed that he even
sold a sword for some cash and now on
the carries around a simple bamboo
takamitsu which is a sign of disrespect
to the Shogun however he's never once
been accused of it Jude how his blade
Cuts Like steel Shion explains that one
time while they were on the booze he
told him that he could perceive the
truth in all things and through there
manipulate someone's momentum by
applying force in certain spots he
claimed that it was something that went
beyond just the waves that xion was able
to perceive and in reality it's fairly
evident that Menzel lined himself with
some Yin or Yang as he was able to
easily reflect all the kunai back into
the ninja also takamitsu by the way
refers to like a bamboo sword carved in
the shape of a like wooden Katana it's
not the Shino which is made up of
bundled slats or a Bakken which is
usually made of heavier wood and
sometimes referred to as like a bakuto
the word taking mitsu can also be used
as a pejorative for a cheap dullaged
blade so pretty much everyone thinks he
has an ass blade but turns out man's
cracked with everyone stunned at just
what happened during becomes confused
because she thought that Shinobi were on
their side but it's told by g-cat that
knew this Shinobi were only pretending
to be allies to complete their main
objective of taking Gabby out Chico like
confesses that he didn't know whether to
side with the iwaka curry or Gabi Maru
but after seeing Gabby decided to stick
with him thinking that they were
somewhat alike although Gaby Murray
disagrees so you see chica he got a few
ladies and that's why uh he thinks him
and Gabby are quite a similar yusu rehab
becomes convinced of jika's abilities
but still finds herself unable to get a
good read on him as the group then
decides to take possession of the
Shinobi's equipment so Gary finds
herself conflicted thinking that they
have to start all over with this insane
situation and knowing that even if they
succeed they're all doomed to slaughter
each other at the end gebimaru though
disagrees as he believes there are a few
differences compared to how they started
and while looking at just how much
everyone has changed yusu riha agrees
but there's a logical thinking of his as
that when he tends to be right and damn
like everyone looks so damn fire all
these new fits on especially chobe Dude
Looks Like so demonic with their mask
it's actually so clean so anyway back to
the story everyone's parents have pretty
much stay the same except this time
instead of being with like usuryha
gabbyus was sagiri since who would doubt
will help us fire and use a riha stays
with Mei to figure out the exact
locations of each Tandon and finally Big
G will team up with jika to help boost
his Earth Dao then with everyone well
equipped and paired up the group set off
to destroy each of the tandons falling
into a memory about the tension though
Zoo Jin remembers Ryan's explanation on
the right of just consumption and
giggles at his poor drawings joofa
notices this smirk and reprimands him to
which the younglin apologizes but
remarks that he can't stand the way too
far picks on them the Tintin knows that
this is all for delphi's sake but finds
it annoying that he's always on the edge
trying to protect them thinking on each
tense and more so Jen goes over all the
good and bad qualities of them and how
at heart they're truly nice people then
remembering how they must work hard so
they don't fail like last time large
white orbs begin appearing in front of
her making her think that she needs to
collect them all to complete the right
of just consumption back in reality
though the amalgamation of zujin's Banco
begins grabbing at the surroundings
doing its base together as many
different types of Dow having made their
way to the shuitsu temple Keo and Isuzu
comfortably destroy a bunch of random
creatures protecting the entrance Isuzu
starts to notice that she is getting
exhausted from staying too long in the
area and finally realizes that this is
why they had to Ally with the criminals
here in her statement and while taking
out a few insects kilomaru tells usuzu
to not doubt shugen's orders as he was
the only one who ever believed in them
shoe can never judge them from coming
from an offshoot Dojo or because they
were young he trained everyone the same
no matter what after remembering the
respect Shogun showed towards him
kiromara reminds her of how he stood up
around the past and was even the person
who got her teaching role Asus who
thanks kiyomaru for reminding her a
better loyalty towards shugen and
remembers the time Shogun pointed out
the Beauty and the color of her skin
having cut their way through the
overgrowth now outside of the palace
Isuzu breaks the door open rushes in and
tells himself that shugen is in the
right standing there inside of the
shuetsu temple the duo finally confront
one of zujin's tandems
after arriving at the banco's Earth
tendon xion tells the rubai to stay back
as he defends against the monsters
approaching them but quickly realizes
that he's nearing his limits they then
hear the sound of the Conch from usuryha
signaling that everyone has reached
their respective tandons and can begin
to destroy them seeing his healthy 10 is
too high up for a sword to rage Sheen
impused naruguay's sword with his
strength and doubt and throws it towards
the Tannen but unfortunately it only
leaves a shallow card and her own Dark
World sojin feels something to take her
hand but can't seem to figure out what
it is reaching forth trying to grab a
ball of Dao it's showing that in reality
she is controlling monsters which are
about to grab the duo she on yours out
to nurugo to stay behind him until the
next sound of the horn since her
inability to use doubt puts her in
danger wanted to speak up naruko
remembers all of the times xion told her
to stay back as he falls alone and
alright his status as Yamada in front of
kiyomaru and ordered a become a guardian
he himself knows that it's due to the
era that he's currently in and has no
hopes of changing any of the laws around
her fate however a man can change
himself off and that's why he decided to
leave the Yamada Clan because like the
legend he has he couldn't condone the
execution of an innocent person nuruka
asks Shion if he meant what he said
during that time to watch he answers yes
after saying that she was happy to hear
him stay there narugo rushes in to
attack the monster herself she already
knows that it's dangerous and remembers
the reasons as to why she cannot
perceive Dao so you see in her clan they
don't believe things that cannot be
touched or seen however after thinking
about what can't be seen and remembering
the feeling she had towards tenza
manages to awaken this ability and
breaks forth into the reality of gods
having cut down a bunch of fodder
creatures with his new technique she
tells Shion that she needs to use her
own strength to survive and asks that he
become her partner instead of a guardian
with a smile on his face she unstates
that his eyes have clearly deceived him
and because his body can't take too much
more asks that she take the lead until
the next enemy horn rings out agreeing
narugo rushes forth and takes the lead
still unable to see themselves zhujin
becomes Fury serious at the random
damage she keeps taking and makes the
Earth tend and Sprout multiple bodies of
Mudan much to xion and the rugai shark
while at the wood Tandon chobe and Tomah
find themselves confronted by clones of
Delphi that have emerged from the Tandon
leading them to believe that the same is
happening at every other tandem that
corresponds with the Dow attributes of
that specific tension the brothers then
begin to ponder on whether they should
make the choice of escaping with the
other survivors or act on Jake's secret
plan of eliminating Shogun in order for
him to make a false report to the Shogun
that they had died so I've actually held
off from saying this a little bit
earlier on because I wanted to but you
see our friendly neighborhood geeky
right here is actually what I consider
to be a first generation Yakuza we know
for a fact that Samurai over time didn't
take the role throughout this period of
Japan as with no war they took different
routes of occupation why he wants
everyone gone also is for the fact that
man wants to be the next leader of the
clan and doing that would be perfect for
him he wants to put this word behind him
for one of luxury instead plus he also
drops the bomb that if xion and segiri
end up Surviving the abandons can take
them down if they please but that's you
know that's just a maybe as well after
the Clones partially transform into the
kishikai state job appears to fight back
but feels his body suffering from the
Bunker's effects on his Dow he also
senses that Tomah is gradually suffering
from the Dow particles in the air and
tries to think of a logical plan going
forward he knows that it's pretty much
impossible to Sag on both the Delphi
Army and destroy the Tandon plus they've
got no time to do the restore glitch
effect telling himself to break apart
once more he knows that he's he's just
got to do it originally it was his plan
to slam back the election with his
brother but now he's leaving everything
up to him without a single worry at all
as he knows he'll win watching his
brother run ahead of him chobo pushes
himself forth and forces Vines out of
his back and all sides that destroy
everything around him meanwhile Gabi
Maro and sagiri are approached by shija
who is Comfortably taken out all of the
goofah Clones flashing back to the
moment where Gabi Mario and sigiri are
confronted by the Goofer clones
themselves shiji comes in and quickly
disposes of them all as the dust begins
to fade it's obvious that she's
extremely delighted to reunite with
then takes the time to talk to shija due
to knowing that the Shinobi is
unpredictable however after hearing the
sound of the Conch siguring reminds him
that they are running at a time and must
either have shiji cooperate with them or
take them on as an enemy Kevin Murrow
tells the Gary that he can't afford to
fight shujo with the current state is in
prompting sigiri to try and perform
their restoration on him saying this and
while calling her a winch should you
darts and behind the two and prepares to
take out sargeri only to Cease the
result in an instant after being ordered
by Gabby Mario to White hearing him out
Gabby Mario just asks her to help as is
in great need of its strength well shija
having like multiple personalities it's
hard to know which way she'll react here
turns out though that she's been waiting
months to hear those words a battle in
her mind between helping the chief or
following her heart happily she agrees
to help Gabby Maro but only in order to
truly resurrect his true self in a sense
she will dedicate her existence to the
sole Revival of History strongest Gabby
Morrow the hollow as shija rushes into
attack and despite his previous injuries
Gabby Mario tells sagiri take down the
regenerated buffer clones behind them
while he handles fighting against shija
shija first starts off your attack by
using ninpo here forced to throw
multiple kunai at Gabi Maro while
dodging him shija then uses the opening
to use nimpo Flash hand to push him
backwards gabrimo dashes out of the way
over kunai and fights her in close
quarters combat whether two using a
multitude of technical techniques to try
and get the other hand of one another
simultaneously both of them in their
initial Clash by using nimpo fire monk
to create a massive explosion knowing
that shiji knows more than like Ninja 2
Venom Gabby Maro speculates that
continuing to fight with taijutsu is
more effective however she's a literally
word for word quotes what Gabi Mario was
thinking and tells them that they are
aware of every move he makes as they
after all spend so much time observing
him despite this and as the two begin
fighting once more get me more tell
shija that they are also able to read
their actions with the help of Dao
having purposefully takes a kick to the
navel in an attempt to send himself
towards the banco's Tandon and destroy
it but ends up only destroying the
statue beneath her shija somehow sees
through him and could tell from the very
start of the fight that he has been
protecting sagiri who they refer to as
the hag they then start to wonder if
Gabby Moe's current state is because of
like the hag's presence and as she
manages to get the upper hand slamming
Gabby Maro into the ground becomes sad
and after saying just how much his body
is suffering from The Waking down
regeneration picking up his face and
staring into his eyes he finds it truly
heartbreaking to say that her love lost
his deadly ferocity and instead chose to
protect others she then realizes in
Anger that sargeria is with gebimaru to
perform their restoration and jumps
towards her Direction and disgust Gabby
Mario yells out to seguri to run however
sagiri refuses stating that she's had
enough she won't stand being called a
hag anymore and prepares to face shija
alone now a little ninja isn't an
immortal scary uses her Dao sensory to
anticipate shizu's attack but is unable
to react in time as in an instant she
appears before her and slams her into
the ground having picked up a special
bag earlier scary pulls it out causing
the female ninja to quickly dart back
and ask why she is allied with Gaby
marrow despite her job
siguri explains that yes once upon a
time she lived to Western code but this
this is no longer their case as an error
Begins the shift it's almost possible to
sympathize with anyone not just Gabby
Morrow but detention and even iwaka
crane ninja after hearing the statement
she just uses her nympho knotted locks
to seem to hear through the ground
before it Springs up restraining to Gary
pinning her down thinking that zagiri
wants to share a similar experience to
herself she makes her inhale the powder
she tossed earlier so you see this
powder is one that manipulates one
sensation and makes them experience an
overwhelming sensation of pain it's
often used in the training of young
ninja which like just like it shows
while shija usually results in only a
few family members surviving this toxin
is known as nerve powder and all an evil
Curry undergo intensive training with
her for three days and three nights
until they acclimate to the pain as her
prepare to give siguri another drug
which is called Never Bliss she explains
that it connects with the pleasure
section of the brain she tells her that
all in Ewa could create are made to be
numb stripped of their senses so that
they only feel feeling they have left is
one of death fear and despair and the
face of death are the only distinct
sensation those in study Clan feel
gamimara first granted her that feeling
and threw her encounter with him she
eventually became aware of her own
mortality yes and that there is death
which embodies life itself death which
comes for all true fleeting life can
only be found in that moment of partying
Yuki back at it with that poetry again
and I had to change things up slightly
for the super morbid side of this like
text right here because of YouTube but I
recommend everyone go and read like this
passage of texts themselves because you
could kind of just pop you off of Hell
how beautifully he constructs a vivid
image with these words inside someone's
mind with his body beginning to suffer
and is Dow depleted as well as sigiri
being unable to combat against shija
Gabby Morrow says that their chances of
Victory are slowly fading away the
second Gabby asks gabimaru why is
desperately clinging to life to what she
answers that he desires to live a normal
life with his wife she just tells Gabby
that his wish cannot come to pass since
iruka Curry will remain in Pursuit
driven fever and his wife does not exist
Hebron denies the thought though as he
knows as the typical psychological
warfare and tries to buy enough time to
recover his doubt and presents an
opening for scary shija she's done
through the majority of this belt sees
through his shame and pleased to Gabby
to come to his senses as they try to
explain that his wife and the life he
shared with her is false pure
make-believe gentis also focuses on
preparing himself to cut down the giant
flower in front of him beside him Jacob
who really ain't came to do that much
right now decides to lay down and put
his faith in against his eye gangster
Society who like interprets his unfazed
Behavior as a test of Courage sits down
next to him wishing to follow along as
well which jiku just found extremely
random he then hears the signal to take
action but is told by jika that the
roots will tell them when the tendons
have been destroyed and when it's the
correct time to take out the main plant
but she questions how he knows this and
jiko explains that he's been able to
understand how things move ever since he
was young like how to inflict a cut or
exactly where a petal would fall his
motto is one of waitang as good things
are bound to come to those who wait
gantees aside though then census that he
is up to something but can't really seem
to get a read on what his intentions are
over with the uh crazy stuff over with
the crazy stalker girlfriend she just
explains to Gabby Mario that like Judah
iwaka Curry's influence no matter how
hard someone craves a normal life it's
simply unattainable the chief's daughter
is no exception at all she possesses no
emotions and has been merely set up to
fake a relationship with him as a way to
hide the atrocities he commits her smile
tastes all the deception crafted to
imprison his mind cut off the the mental
stuff going on right now though I need
to point out how cracked you he is again
for like the 20th time this here is a
representation of bunraku Theater which
is super dope like you're the old like
public theater except these bodies are
like the size of actual humans and the
bodies are usually controlled by up to
like three different people it's just
perfect imagery to show how manipulated
and controlled Gabby's life has been
with his wife with this in mind though
she begs for Gabby to revert back to his
former self and throw away any idea of a
normal life after hearing shades are out
sigiri awkwardly Smiles as she looks up
at Gabby Maro standing back up like
lights are Gary suspected all our boy
needed was a confirmation that she does
indeed exist she you kind of miss you
kind of messed up there we know for a
fact that his Dow explodes whenever his
wife is mentioned and for him these
feelings are tied to strength and
weakness due to that and because of how
and hell's Paradise the Dual forces of
Yin and Yang can affect someone's body
and mine alike his body is then shown
recovering after us Dao becomes
stabilized from the confirmation he
received of his wife truly existing
standing there Gabby Mario remembers the
words you imparted to him that this is
the better we call life and it's
important to preserve a little normalcy
at times confidently he tells shija that
he always knew his dream would come at a
price but now he's ready to search for a
new normal life with her with you with
his wife by his side with his body back
to normal gabimaru boldly states that
shija that they will not have an
advantage over him and will not allow
him to get away with this no matter what
this causes Shazier to remember their
past confrontation with him when they
were children where he stated the exact
same thing get in my way and I'll take
you out chicha let them mean to okay she
is then becomes Overjoyed with Gabby
marrow's Newfound attitude screaming
that this this is indeed perfect any
past memory yui explains to Gabby Mario
how to properly prepare chair starts
after Gabby questions the like the point
behind it all yui tells him that she
doesn't quite understand herself she
just wanted to try the normal way since
growing up in Ewa wasn't normal at all
the toe then sit down to eat Chestnut
rice which you say she found to be very
delicious and sweet Gabby though staring
at his plate just wonders if it really
was since he wouldn't know she'd always
sense of taste is dulled you who's
actually sadly in the same situation
then tells him that by saying it out
loud they can at least pretend to be
normal
back in the present now and during the
current battle Gabby Morrow says that he
has not lost his battle instincts it's
just that the battlefield in general
forehand has changed referring to his
memories of how like he could not
understand his wife's struggle before at
first he never understood why she would
do something so Random it just seemed
like meaningless drudgery to him what
was the point of food the normalcy he
could never even figure it out looking
up into his eyes she just figures out
that gabimaru's love has no clear signs
of weakness and a last-ditch effort
attacks with everything that was taught
to them by Gabby that's in Adam she
tries to strike his vitals but to no
avail throwing a kick Gabby effortlessly
leans back out of the way before
blocking a follow-up strike thrown by
her jumping back she remembers the time
Gabby told her she'd never be able to
master acidic Blaze before pulling her
hand up to her face and releasing a huge
torrent of flames after using her own
acidic Blaze she just boosts forth
pushing the Flames aside and somehow
managing to stab Gabby maro's heart
nonchalantly though looking down at his
entry give him our Applause the shija
for a dipped use of the ability explain
that if he was still human they might
have just killed him now though and
because he's making it home no matter
what he grabs her hand pulls her in
close and activates nympho ascetic Blaze
full fire completely sitting the jewel
with lights after being engulfed by
Gabby Morrow's fine and Jitsu change
your thinks back over a sad existence
she remembers how everyone had
admiration for Gabby but hers was
different something more she wonders
what it was what she felt she thinks
about the time she fled from Gabby Mario
when they were children and questions if
the reason was because she feared that
she might have died as time slowly moved
forth she's a court wind of Gabby marrow
being married to you and tries to mirror
her appearance by burning the right side
of her face in reality though and she's
known herself for a while that the
pounding of her heart wasn't born from
admiration nor from dread but sadly the
time for thinking of that had indeed
passed having collapsed at the ground
with a smile on her face chicha with
their last bit of strength creates a
large whistle from the hair and signals
all of the irregular Croatian Obi asking
what the signal was for or it's revealed
that it was in fact a cleansing ritual
one to clearly passed forth for Gabby
and the last nympho she'll ever use they
also tell him that you was indeed alive
and awaiting his return apparently the
chief like hadn't actually planned to do
anything until after all of the uh
Shinobi returned confirming Gabby's
death then he was gonna deal with his
daughter with a final breath she asks
Gabby that if she's ever reborn in
sickness and in health until death threw
them part would he faced him once more
to what she answers yes well they smile
on his face chicha happily thanks Gabby
Maro for his answer and wishes them luck
in his future battles I'd love to know
your thoughts on Shader down in the
comment section below damn I thought she
was too crazy when she first showed up
but like over the short amount of time
that she was in the story I guess right
here who Dynamics is really damn cool
and the idea that she was the next Gabby
kind of like resonated with me that she
had to kill Gabby there she wanted to
take their position moving forth now
sahiri rolls over to Gabby and is told
by him that they need to refocus their
attention back on a destroying the
tandem wallet story generating with
everyone around being in the prime
position use a rehears sounds off the
next signal and all 14 simultaneously
prepare to destroy the tandems over with
the big chillers though jika begins
getting back up on his feet after
sitting in the timing is right for him
and getting him to decide to destroy the
barn Co yet as Big G himself begins to
stand up he states that this thing might
be uh might be slightly difficult
revealing the titan-sized barn code that
had begun taking on a completely new
transformation in preparation to take on
the new transform monster and I
absolutely love this part of the story
man Jacob against tossing off all his
clothing as a way to maintain his
spiritual focus and asks skin tape
Society at the same time for a sword
genital odd that he doesn't have a
strong enough weapon to cut down the
zujin fused banko but after looking at
his surroundings and witnessing bodies
of zhujin sprouting out of vines gantage
design chooses to follow with zika's
plan and gives him his sword as I said
this part is mean to where I hear Boys
the slight bestowed he he is him using
his own special intuition jika sent us
all of the fatally wrong moves that he
could make as he walks forth to take out
the monster eventually after casually
strolling past countless spots where he
died in an instant chica comes to a good
position with the right factors like
wind and presence around him to cut down
the monster finding that it is all in
sync now chica swings against his sword
and successfully cuts down the head of
the zhujin fused banko from a distance
just like he did in the past with the
ocean monster having watched this
unfathomable feet gente's aside becomes
astonished and remembers the time that
he believed defeating monsters would
lead him down the path of Legends
standing in front of him now is exactly
the sort of man to go down in history as
a god Slayer thinking on lightly past
some more he also remembers when
fujifudadoshi and refused to explain why
as a baby clone of zujin approaches him
now can't touch his eye state that he
started to understand where Fuji was
coming from and that fighting monsters
in order to give him a thrill in his old
age doesn't affect him anymore in front
of him and having walked across a field
of flowers chica steps up to the Tandon
and prepares to destroy it gentistic
tries warning him that if he should
proceed then it might also have an
effect on kebimaru and chobe since the
Dow was connected with the monster
despite being told this though chica
ignores the risks and utterly destroys
the tandem with his Zu gen fused Banco
destroyed all traces of its remnants
slowly start to wilt away however jika
engines soon realized that the giant
creature is still somehow alive this is
due to it already been mourning as worn
before by May and now because of that
they must take on the task of
destroyingly tendon simultaneously again
Toby says that the wood tendon is
beginning to slowly regenerate from the
Sun and finds himself too low on stamina
to make another attempt and destroying
it Tommy yells out suggesting the toby
and leaving the monster behind and
trying to find a way off the island
together instead in his eyes there's no
reason to die in here as that would make
him no different to their father despite
his brother's plea Toba activates his
breakdown State one last time and uses
his Vines to dig into the wood Tandon he
knows he doesn't have the right
attribute but securing the roots with
his Vines will allow him to cut off the
Regeneration to the main body with only
one job left he chose us to do that
exact method with each and every
location as he can fully destroy the
immortal through that method his plan
ends up becoming a success as everyone
around watches chobe's Vines burst
through all of the tandems in each
location one last time our demon Bandit
says break down and come the hell apart
but not on himself instead on the
immortal Banco which as a result starts
to finally weather away having used up
his strength chubby falls to the ground
and hears his brother crying out to him
falling into a flashback of his own he
remembers all of the times how Toma is a
baby and how he felt like he could break
apart at any second but still crept onto
him for dear life once realizing that he
must protect the little one as his older
brother chobe with tears in his eyes
says that he protected him because
that's what big brothers do and the
afterlife chubby kneels down before his
parents and apologizes for the sins he
had committed in his life but was happy
to say that it was at least a good
brother a young chobe then runs to his
parents with open arms as does life
finally comes to an end randomly though
and breaking through the light he
notices a hand reach out to him after
the passing of his older brother Tomah
kneels down in total grief while holding
on to what seems like a plant like ovule
meanwhile man use a rehab run out of the
temple while complaining about the foul
odor in the air and encounter goofah as
a child who's holding onto this random
base and earned looking thing
stuck in the corner of my room help so
that officially brings us to the very
end of the harai arc here with hell's
Paradise honestly this is probably the
best Arc throughout the series so far
just because it has the the climax and
the culmination of pretty much like all
of the fights that we've wanted to see
you know Xi'an finally getting his main
fight against the uh the tencent and all
that kind of jazz but kind of what I
want to talk about here is the massive
amount of depths that we did see
throughout this part of the arc like we
had fuchsi and chobe from the main group
which is just insane to think that they
actually departed from our group like
like I never expected when I first
started reading through the series that
Cho Bay would actually pass on like that
the hints were there earlier on but I
never ever actually picked up on them
out of the tents and I'm pretty sure
we've lost ran juffa dalfa and uh zhujin
which you know tune into the
amalgamation there at the very end but
ended up you know dying along with chobe
and stuff uh obviously we've still got
Goofer who's you know holding the pot
May who's Big chilling with the the
group still in every big chilling with
usuryha right now and then obviously you
know the one and only Ren which is over
on the boat trying to sail it to the
mainland doing their best to you know
subdue all the fires and everything and
that there is what we're going to be
going over and the final Arc and then
the next video which is a lot shorter
than this one so I should be able to get
it out in like a week or two the reason
this has taken me a lot longer than
usual is that I've just had a lot of
like family stuff going on in general
like I don't I don't want to get into
too many details but pretty much turns
out I've actually got a tear on the back
of my aisle like on the back of my
retina and it's been extremely hard for
me to even concentrate on kind of like
words like I can't look at my scripts
and read these words that I I used to be
able to read perfectly fine and it's and
it's kind of got a little bit annoying
as you could imagine and to add to that
as well I've gone and had you know like
my wisdom teeth come through for the
past like three to five months now so
that there has just been adding an extra
level of like Stress and Anxiety to
everything and for some reason it's been
piling on to me more than it usually
would so you know it's taken me a little
bit long going to get this video out
just because I had so much stuff going
on and not even to mention that mum's
going in and out of the hospital right
now as well so there's just a lot going
on in life and I hope you all understand
that sometimes it's you know I love to
eat it but it's you know I've got to put
that aside and look after myself at the
end of the day and look after you know
like my mum she's getting older and but
yeah like on a funny note though the way
I did ended up like ruining my eye and
getting these these gangster glasses
like look at these like I can't really
actually see the camera right now
because it's called blurry they're only
good for like reading close-up and all
that kind of jazz but the reason I
messed up my eye was I was playing
freaking uh like Harry you know like
they walk back and forth and they do
that whole thing when they stand back to
front and then they walk like to the end
of the Platforms in Harry Potter and
then they'll do that like boom well here
in New Zealand we have like these Roman
candles which are big long fireworks
like this and I decided that it would be
a great idea for me to you know
and that reenact the scene from Harry
Potter with one of my mates while we
were drinking on like a 21st or a 22nd
birthday of like a another good friend
of ours and right at the very start of
the night I suffered a firework straight
to my eye and it left me I I literally
the entire night I was blinded and I
couldn't even see anything or understand
I can't even remember that night at all
like it's a complete blank in my vision
but yeah that firework left me uh
partially blinded in this eye right here
and over time it's gotten slowly like
gradually worse I guess you could say
with fear level of blurriness that is
coming or like you know moving over my
eye and whatnot and that just turns out
to be because my Readiness teared but
yeah obviously pushing that all aside
for now because I do need to end the
video but it's been far too long that
we've been sitting here of course go and
check out Swipe mouse pads and obviously
join the Discord down below or like
message me on Twitter and let me know
what your sit-ups look like once you
have got your mouse pads I'd love to
actually know because
so clean and they're so nice so like
honestly I do recommend it like I don't
really do sponsors that much anymore
because I don't want to push some shitty
old mobile game so go and actually like
check them out they're a really really
proper good mouse pad and I'm not going
to be using any other mouse pad apart
from swipe from now on most likely
because they're freaking dope but anyway
enough of that subscribe if you are new
around here and push this video to 5K
like so that I know you all want the
last part in this series but for now
it's been in professional degenerate
dfolio and I will see you all in a boat
bye